And one bedrooms baby girl
But just know the screen running and if you
in front of the green light if you can see
the green light it probably
Why
Can you free oh my god when did the screen
get here
Are you
I want to make an adventure game we can walk
around them
On that that on the HTML he was talking
about
That's what I'm saying
If you do that I will help you I will make a
store system I will help you build the
battle system back up I will help you all
along the way bro I will help you cuz I want
to do this I want to create a game then we
can all play especially if we could play
this game together
Can you imagine going to shit aria.com
We can put the yeah we can put it on my site
but it's not going to take I don't want it I
don't want the game and website or you can
put that on a page on your site that ain't
got to be your whole site
I'm going to have it on the big homie cheese
under adventure games
Did I buy to be coming cheese I did not we
still got like $6 to spend on domain about
to get we are stormed out today I'm done
waiting
But it's $79 man
I don't know manAll right so.
Since you ain't agree with the adventure
game I'm going to just put the idea
With the question mark
OK Google
Beside Clans
I'll be back like busy I only got the
Glass will goAnd then.
You can hit somebody
In Spanish no baby I got the sandwich I'm
good
You make money back
For you
I'm ready when you Harbor sorry I'm talking
about
In Batman 19 minutes call me you're not
coming
Okay
Yes comma
You don't even need the chat well I don't
know nothing
I'm going to fly football
Where's my hair we are waiting on garbage
who has to do
With pancakes
The other girl just said she'll know how to
cook the pancakes and never did that brand
before
Are you
That might be her way upstairs
Otherwise we'll be way louder in here
Like to catch you except I have nothing to
go upstairs this is already bare maximum I
can take
Like it's already like
Just low enough not for me to say nothing
but high enough to make me mad that's right
And then press the booty
Airboat wait no one is gone
I need to go check
I am
Exclamation point
Ari that's not going to try start moving it
you know what okay
I can't pick up the bandages
You can't pick them up either I'm stupid or
I'm done
Never mind I'm stupid all right since I'm
stupid I'm leaving now it's cool
Anyway so by the time cuz I might be back by
the time now
Yeah I literally always
OhI'm going to go.
I told you
It won't let me pick up the lamp
Did you get that black rock from before Aria
Okay okay
Carmen
Nope I'm just getting on the train and leave
me up
Interesting
I don't know I'm trying to put the Rock
Ets
Something just hit me bro I ain't playing it
I don't play that I don't play that I don't
play that bet you don't hear me again yep
you're up
He did
How is this the same place how we in the
same location
S
Two three
Yes sir
You love yourself
But I had a bandage on meIt was two guys
over there.
They're already halfway they're heading
towards Carmen Carmen is two guys behind you
Cuz I got a bandage
Wait what's up what's back
Oh it's three more hold up I didn't knowI
got you on the bandage if I get these kills
in.
I'm trying not to take damage here
On my way to you
How do I revolve with dinosaur
Done with them
On my tech working today
I already goAll right all aboard.
My stuffHold up.
Here
All right let's go manYou need to get to a
town I need a gun man.
Needed to beat somebody up laterYeah.
What is that stick sticking out the wall
what is that
Alright
Step back step back step backStep back step
back.
Holy I got you
No no somebody
We got a little bit more fuel and CaptainCan
I knock down this tree.
I think we ready to go
Right here
Oh my bad put
Never going to die
Okay
Stop stop oh never mind never mind I got it
It won't let me put it in there I'll tryAnd
fell off.
I'm going to that house I'm going well I'm
not I'm not I doHow do we get help back.
I feel like we should have went in there
broMama ain't raise no bitch.
Okay
It's it's a bunch of stuff in that house too
No I didAin't nobody saved me man.
Yeah I don't care about me run out there on
a crash dummy ain't nobody say no Dad don't
do it no Uncle Vick I don't know how to play
these games I just be ready to go I just be
ready to roll
Do you blame meCuz what is she doing right
now other than dying.
At leastSix.
Everyone dies
ElYou good.
Okay
Did I press the button
I am trying to two times some stuff so this
time I'm getting too bandage if y'all died
so fast that was crazy train
No noOkay okay.
What do we do with these newspaper notes
The other one did not work because that's a
different it's a telegraph I know it's not
it's not I'm going to the trade in post with
this
Yeah are you on you know what
No let me get the girl
Where
I don't see it in hereOh I know what you're
talking about you talking about the alcohol
it's this place.
I've been forgetting even check over here I
ain't even check over here
I don'tI don't like you like that. REI
movement.
No it's not letting meYou got to get stuff
to stay over.
ImagineWhy is it not letting me get it bro.
Did you buy a Band-Aid already or your
number
If not I'll buy you one minute SiriTake two.
I want to crossbow too
Yeah you got 25 minutes
Stop let me grab it let me grab it let me
get thereYeah I got it I got it I got it I
got it.
You help you up we ready to go now I can
defend us are we on they done messed up we
got two Defenders no deaths
I don't know but I'm leaving now
I'm running baby just what is this Sheriff
Please Outlaws here to claim Bounty I don't
know what that mean that's those guys that
shot at us and I've been waiting to get my
get back on one of them dudes too so let's
go or whenever y'all get here we can go are
you said we was able to mind those rocks
right I bet you we could sell those rocks
for money is there a pickaxe
What do you do with the rock stand that we
picked out the rock thing
You got dragged dragon and then throw it on
the ground wait which game you on you on
that one
She ran out to me on the same pageI've been
gone.
Cuz I wanted to see
Some things are running after meBut I'm
killing them so.
You want some two buckle
I feelYeah and the other ones up there too.
Yeah I can store it.
I'll get the other one that's up there for
meNow we got fuel.
Want to go a little farther or we come back
I'm at like 75 health
All right let's go over there how many
bullets you got I got 15 minutes okay I'm
just trying to get back to where the people
shooting with guns for a little bit
I would say bring the train a little but it
ain't going to make it so far it ain't going
to make it no far but I do think what we
just did was definitely the move and then we
can also check going out the back way too if
I'm correct heading our way here
Heard the yeah I hear the wolf yeah I hear
you I mean like I said I'm not tripping I
really
Where you atYeah I didn't want to waste my
bullets.
That's why it's like cool to stay around
here for a little bit like we don't got to
leave bro yeah I got this one
My problem was I was too defending on them
trying not to waste my stuffNah you got to
defend yourself.
I'm hearing the bullets I'm not saying no
You mean
Right now
Bro
Ccoli it won't let me put my wolf in there
it won't answer really wait let me see
Then go see if you can sell it at the Bounty
or something
But it definitely just did not let me
unstore mine
Interesting
Cuz I also have one was I not supposed to
put it in mind
And it's nothing
With one less space cuz I don't know what to
do
All right when you're readyCuz I give up on
this I'm active.
Huh yeah I told you I put like six things in
there bro
Go ahead get to the back
I got you again
And I need to pick X I'm getting a pickaxe
next time
We got crossbows I can't cuz you going too
fast
If they do damageYou might want to. I want
to start going now.
Start going outGo. Go bro.
I don't know but if you don't go we did for
sure
She did we got to leave her cuz I ain't
going to lie to you
I ain't going to lie to you
That's whyAnd we went past the house.
No I'm going to go back even though those
dudes about to kill us it's just going to be
a restart we can't leave body behind
Yeah I find some in this house to put that
rock guy down cuz you know they're on the
wayLike I see him already on the way.
They on their way
You worried about the wrong thingCan we can
we can we get somewhere safe and block these
guys out.
YesWhy would you run out there.
Look I don't think it's like that all the
time I don't know
We should have ran back to the town on them
boys that's what we should do
What she died
Yeah yeah let's go let's get it let's get it
another try another try number four
I need something good out of here they
didn't get the crossbow it's time but what
is this red blender Bliss guns
That's the same as cheese are youThat's
definitely lame is cheese energy.
The blender
I'm really going how far this time cuzI
ain't got a weapon.
All I got is a show
Er
The most difficult person I've ever metWant
a problem.
Something you always get it and then I never
got stood what you want what do you want me
to buy for you it's 50 dollars it's about to
be my last hamburger appreciate you bro
They think they slick you can't even go
backwardsThis game is only forward.
I'm at a whole another time
I can find a whole another train I'm about
to leave you
Wait what do you mean y'all got to do
pancake and Siri what's going on
Online I just went back behind it
Here
Microsoft basketball championship
I'll start shopping
List
Did anybody already bought bandages
It's an outlaw
You don't understand what that means it's an
outlaw on a horse
I would tell you turn back aroundBecause
it's a Outlaw on a horse unless you got a
gun.
I got a gun okay I'm glad to see I'm glad to
hear it this Baldwin yeah come on bring your
bowl that's where I'm at
Or are we ready because this is what I'm
talking about like what are y'all doing at
the town right now where I have already
visited a bandit
I've already hid from him lost him and y'all
have not left the building I'm about to be
back at the building
And it's about to be night timeNow you're
about to run me over.
Yeah I see you coming right now
Hopping onAbout time your car back up.
Wait somebody better hold it
On the front of the boat
Did they even
What is another one
Then move to the backStop staying forward
facing I just fell underneath the car.
Bro when we here attack who's
drivingWhoever's driving is doing an ass job
right now.
You got to stop when we get into situations
cuz they don't help us I put your stuff
right here on the bike
But like I was saying are you when you get
in the situations you can't just keep
sitting there forward in the face saying in
the front complaining about oh I'm about to
die like move behind the people with life
Like who is that person right thereAbout to
die okay the truck still running the whole
time.
But you don't hearAll the parts.
I'm trying to save them and I got leftI
ain't even know the truck was moving I
thought she was helping us kill everything.
Cuz not it's not the thing that would be
cool but they be on the train with us so we
got to like handle the things that are like
on there you're the safest cuz you're the
farthest one behind but everybody else is
getting like mashed up
Don't blame me for how slow Roblox makes
y'all move
Ment
We didThe house.
We got barbed wire two chairs two chairs
Google
All right you could go
There's some dogs are that's cool
Do not put it in your inventoryLike it's
going to get stuck just put it right in
here.
It dip off for a little minute cuz of
thatGrab it. Cuz.
All right I'm driving sorry lowest Health
needs to drive by the way
We doing good on gas too
I ain't seen nothing to tell you to stop yet
man keep it real
Oh it's coming up though we get wait we
going to pass this up right
Pass it up you want to pass up the big town
with all the damn zombies or not
At least move further down like this too
much to attack at once let's come in and
yeah
Maybe we can I think now
That way we don't got to fight them all at
once they come as supposed to be in
surrounded
Yeah
They're not running towards us so we can
pick these guys off one on one and look
likeThat's perfect.
Come on my mind
It's night time hold up call me call me okay
I can't even see him now they starting to go
crazy cuz it's night time y'all
Does anybody
It's wondering afterIt's the disappearing
when I see.
Me too we got to just passed that place up
it's tempting but we got to just pass it up
bro
Sound like she just got downstairs
Wow you've been quiet long morning
I open my eyes yeah somebody else get that
money
She might just be crying just cuz she won't
be picked upIf you do that.
She do do thatIt was 30.
I wantedDone.
Yeah I wish you could do that you got that
one we only need
Who's got the 50 things
I had to pick up
Yep and I got a Molotov
It's what we going to use to blow up those
guys when they go to that thing
I didn't get them all the time but it's 35
but I'm I'm kind of like manI got to pick
up.
You want the pickaxe too
We get two pickaxes and try and come back
and what is this you can't wait
It won't let you bring you
To a buddy's only got 40 left
We got to pickaxe and we got to goWho wants
the Navy revolver. Community.
I'm leaving with AriaWaiting on these slow
people anyway.
Let me know if you see one of those rocks I
want to go ride
I definitely see something with a light in
front of us yeah that's nervous
Hey you got the gun where you at Gun Woman
Is it coming towards I'm sorry
Baby
Never mind
Yeah yeah yeah you got that I'm hiding
behind the rock over here
I thought I could hide they came for me next
I should have jumped on with you
Hey you know what though I put in workI
killed one of them.
She got the other
One to get bandages cuz those are definitely
So take him to the outlaw
Picking my shit I don't like that
He's playing the game
All three of us and there's two other guys
over here
Worth it
I'm close to the house
I'm over hereUp to the house and all that
time. That's what I'm saying.
Anything
Drop me right thereAll right.
That's it for me like I don't know I can't
do the crime and everything y'all y'all got
to bring her upstairs or something
Excuse me mama
Jakayla I really can't I just can't do this
like you got to bring her up to the room or
something like cuz I don't want to hear that
I don't want to hear that
That's no offense to you no offense to the
baby I justCan't do it.
Again
You want me to drive or you got it all right
now
It's like 3 hours shit a minute
Do you have to go tell her to come tonight
How long does it take
Me like right here y'all better have a whole
bunch of suits and armors and a whole bunch
of stuff cuz like what did we buy y'all
ain't got three bandages and came back
Is that not crazy nobody that took 20
minutes to just go get bandages and come
back
And yeah I'm about to walk back
Cuz I got $70 I'm about to cash in on
I'm about to definitely see if it take that
long cuz I'm going to walk all the way back
and run all the way
How do I heal itWhere's the guy thing at.
The guy the
Right but we should be taking it and giving
it back cuz that's $35 and it's another
horse over here
But how do we heal the horseCuz I feel like
it's getting worser.
Yeah
All right so note to self don't kill the
horse kill the guy
I just need to know if this is hurting the
horse me riding it
And did you bring the bodyPerfect.
My name is no dad but where's that same the
same Hill for the last time you wrote it
it's okay okay
You want to tryYou play the rest of his life
for me I got something I got to do.
What I can't hear you
After I saved you I gave you the gun and
where were you when the people were going to
change it when my ex pulled up on me and
jumped me near the rock where
Where was you at yeah you got to get back
but it shouldn't have been to get back cuz
you should have been there
All right bro
Well did you
Oh my God so one circles in the town
Respectfully how much money did you get for
them Bandits I got $70 okay
?You don't leave outside.
Besides Carmen left us at the beginning of
the game and I still don't know what she did
You just got to wait
Oh there it goes
I thinkOh yeah.
First play again with the same team
Okay
For real yeah actually did not come here I
see you girl hey baby girl back here let me
Know
Yeah
GoogleGoogle.
And go off I need you to go get the gun get
the gold bar and go get the gift
You are not going to break
It depends on if they got to pick it cuz I'm
going to get the tickets I don't even get to
try to pick eggs but it did hurt to
It did hurt the what you call it guys I
wonder if it hurts the rock guys
On the keyboard
I'm going to make one
Okay how many people in here
How many people
It's still six feet boots
It's cuz got into another one so he joined
ours then look
For youGo to school. And go this way.
Okay y'all going to make one
To make money
It is not my fault that you did not get a
game off in the time that it took me to do
So I'm right here
You lost your privileges I don't know which
I was doing I don't know what happened
I can't depend on y'all not lasting long
without me
I did try though what is they doing on my TV
and not playing with us
And do they got eight player games
Okay so why we planning afford that's crazy
Are you counting my money
Out in my money I got my money
Bad world
So everybody respond but you feel me on why
right like I'm not crazy like this and these
options are but like they're buns
Like I lied I'm the longest living I win
Bro
Attention always end up on my floor and for
me to clean up and put somebody else to
clean up but somebody I don't know I don't
know I don't know
Sorry okay everybody died
In her room cuz she kept something and it
broke it broke her stuff
Good stuff are not good stuff
Okay signAture no they don't got.
The paper okay
That's okay let me tell Carmen to give me
something
Okay hello I always see the arrows up in
this place now I don't know if they there
this time
Cuz if they don't got both of them I don't
want it I'd rather go to that gun store
So cuz the land of I think about it the
landmine explode the landmine explode when
they run over it right
Now
So if we can set it up like we did where we
came up at him and they were starting to
come out of slowly we could even take the
whole mob the bad thing was it turned night
time I really feel like if it had night time
like if we could have just waited and stood
it out till the morning healed up and came
in on a date daytime then we would have been
good we got to keep track of the time when
we come up to that City
Okay hold up hold up who touched the town
hall
Okay I just bought this
Okay let me get to my site I got to get to
my side
Oh this is easy
Y'all open to start the train we haven't put
the I'm going to put the car in there
All right now
Treatment for the family pledge authorities
are Urgent also viruses the drug
Oh I got it finally I finally got itOh I'm
scared for this.
The bag of topOh inventory at the top you
could drop 10.
Oh I just put the fuel in thereAnd you can
drop and you could drop Emma okay.
So yeah we got a shovel I got to shovel
intercept
Period
I'm ready
Too slow Mario
I'm in the chair hold up okay
Are you ready you ready to take off all
right
But the thing is like we're still at zero
meters
I'm scared for this now I got to get myself
up
Oh no hello hello
Oh my God
The house right there sleep all day
You got one
They got three guys on horses with guns
Straight up last night
You going to the house I'm not alive
I think
Carlos tomorrow
Oh it's morning time
You still got about the people though he
just did nighttime I can oh no it was just
doing this second
Back be careful cuz there's people
And I better start shooting I meant we can't
shoot
I'm dead we all didAll we got replaced.
I just don't I started jumping the trainer
but I did that on accident
Everybody did find a distanceOkay close to
something.
Wait on one person
I wish illegal 13 seconds
And somebody not playingOkay.
I don't know
It was only 10 it was only meIt was only. A
ride didn't pick it.
I mean I already get off and restart respond
What I'm playing a game
You still want to playCuz it's only me and
you.
You know and it started raining
It says you want to play
Why are we in the game
Okay you all right
Let me see your chicken
You join it cool let's do it
Good
Okay bitch
Bro you can have 10 peopleYes.
Cuz we could have 10 people in the partyExit
how many people here.
Yeah everybody get a device get in get
onGame game.
Everybody get in get a game get on here
Yeah I don't want random so that's the thing
I want I just want all of us
I know I just want to sell their coins and
leave them stranded
So how does somebody get it before me
Okay she's going to come home
Yeah okayOkay. Everybody how many.
Four it's Carmen's in one
87Six.
Okay okay
Cuz I'm trying to get this goldYou want it
yeah okay.
No it's a 20 my bad let me move
Up
Don't think I should get this done how much
is itIt's 50.
I'm about to get a better priceYou like that
man who gets better prices to everything.
I think you're going to say no cuz I'm about
to ask her for 10 againYou got me some
watching okay.
Let me know
Let me say this you can get the rest of my
money I might have like 20 minutes
Bro
BroYou're being irritating.
I don't need a play-by-play for everybody
you press
Okay
Can I just go
Up and you just meet me up there for the
trainOr you can just go right now.
Carmen probably left our ass
Please
I should have learned last time
I learned my list
Yeah I got angle I'm leaving everybody
Is that people shooting at usYou think I'm
about to stop hell no I'm not going to the
bus.
Did you jump off
Children fell off but we stop
Well we kind of got to go back to get her
cuz she fell off the butt
And then we also got to pick up the guy that
fell soWish us luck.
But I would have preferred to just leave
that alone
You get some children you did yeah but by
the way I ain't got no bullets I ain't got
no what's up
I got a bunch of fuel you toss it in I'll go
save herNo wait it's some people.
HereThey're behind you too.
If I can make it I'm not going to make itIt
was good.
No she want to join back in the game bro
Carmen she said she left she had to go to
the bathroom
Good girl
Can one of y'all about bandages
Wow never mind that I'm not getting the
bandage no we don't no we only need
Sapphire
OkayYou already went up there I was going to
try to train up there.
You don't want to turn up there
I'm probably farther out than y'all get this
game
Oh there's the buttHow far did I get.
2000 sorry
I don't I think we need the saddle
Everybody goingTo. Did it extreme I think
you need a saddle to catch him.
Cuz I've killed one before and it didn't let
me Smash the bodySo that mean that.
Okay running out there it's just what I'll
do to keep myself entertained while I wait
on you slow steps but here comes out
Stop it's like three zombies in there
You can charge your first yearHard to hit
charge a hit.
Yeah when we coming out yeah that's what I'm
saying we should charge it here when we run
up on them
Or shine about that now
You're excited don't let me get excited
nothing
Go hit that
Yeah I'm not going in the house
You need help picking those up
Pickaxe much needed
Yep I already know we can drive but ain't no
stopping
That charge the hit thing that's that's how
we attack them in groups
I just not going in tonight or should we go
go for it Mom and raise no bitch
Just hold a charge where is it at I don't
see the zombie coming
Yeah I headed towards the house I'm going
inIt's three of them in there four of them
in there.
It's four of them in there y'all comingLet
me know when y'all close I'm going in
without.
Y'all need help
For sure we need to pick this up right here
OkayDid you get all the stuff from the house
so listen this stuff in here.
Fluted
I'm just going to chill up on the truck well
I'm losing itYeah that's what it means bro.
Let's go get it but I already got the stuff
it ain't nothing to grab it was just some
chairs
YeahThank you.
I mean can you break these regular rocks or
no can you break those regular routes
There's a rock really close to us that you
had to go that far butAnyway.
You go to the one you can crash cuz it's
rock you can't hit
Okay
I didn't try to but I used Obama
Can I go to see a house tonight
It's two zombies in there landline
Wonder how much damage to tell my heart does
Well to activate
My ass in mind
Is it through it
Wait I want to rotate itSo we can shoot off
the back.
Wait I just need to
All right now
Okay so we should we don't know what the
bandage I had dropped if I don't know that
acid trap would have been perfect for the
office
Especially at that house but I'm thinking
right there and then we like
Bro yes
But I need ballista ammo not crossbow arrows
okay babe
No hell no I'm definitely not Richard
We definitely need to get back on and get
back on and let's go oh my God go go go go
go go go go go go go
Home
I swear it's not me
He didn'tWe got to leave cuz he left the
game.
All that
So you going so much more I can take playing
with you playing like this
I need my boy CharlieWhere is Charlie at.
Let me know when you're out here
Haven't talked about someToday. What we
going to do today and if we're not doing
anything is it okay if we could go downtown.
It ain't workingOh I don't know exit.
And she's you still tried to you you went in
I understand completely
Video games
We need a letter
Children's Hospital
I'm going to go
All right
Yeah Romeo no it's kind of cool cuz it
actually killed the wolves
Ain't shit
Did you get a picture
The person
Is this your hands are rifleI can pick it
up.
You already pick up the email
So maybe I do
It's some rifle ammo come get it since you
got arrested
What the fucker this is the second letter
I don't know I kind of want to stand here
overnight yeah like you did last time with a
Any better place itCuz I can weld it.
Oh I can't weld it
I don't have room otherwise I would haveCan
you grab it and walk cuz I can.
Okay I got an idea
And that's what the sheetrock metals are for
so we can make a base anywhere I got it you
know
We can pretty much just keep riding until
the till the daytime go
Are you getting attacked no you're just
doing that to do that
There's a house right
Or you could have got out and helped one of
us and nobody would have died
Bubble bubble OK Google
You don't feel like it was necessary to tell
us that it was five times
AfterThe rest.
Of crazyAll I'm saying is if you died or
something.
And it's people back there I'm trying to
figure out why she died
First
So we're not going to do that no moreI'm
going to get the money rocks.
So many rocks bro that pickaxe is so useful
bro them bandages really not like got them
bandages are a fake you not supposed to be
done I didn't even get a chance man
But they don't got the balls so
That's coolThis is already started my book
bro.
And when I get the money I'm just down for
breaking it down evenly 2020 and then give
me the 10 I don't care
That way you can get what you want if you
want to get fuel you can give fuel cuz we
don't even got to get that cold yet
Fuel from rocks when the zombies come at
night we can smash on them right at the
right at the base
With the people helping us shoot it to get
the fuel we did that and filled upI thought
I already clicked it it's not me it's her.
That shit
GrandmaLooking more like Grandma.
And she in her own world too
Oh wow mama
The saddle saddle I'm with the saddle but I
don't want it cuz I don't know how to catch
that thing but I was doing what is this I
still want to know I want this it never let
us get this sore
Is there anything I went 30
Too late
Okay that's 15 yearsIt doesn't.
Matter
If my defenseRespond everybody.
It don't matter cuz we have a pickaxe in my
defense
I didn't know for sure if that was going to
work
I'd ran by the I was moving it and I was
going to put it in the in the cabin with the
driver right
And I let it touch the fire
And then it lit it and then I panicked I
didn't know I didn't have a plan for if it
actually let it
Cuz I didn't think it was going to light it
yeah yeah but now I know how to use it
because like that's what I was trying to do
it didn't have like a activate button like
you don't press e to activate it
Yeah me too and then it wouldn't let you
pick it up and like put it in your inventory
so I was like what the heck
I thought I was going to have to weld It To
The Ground like that ballista so that is my
fault I'll take that okay
So we could do that experiment
And we also got the crossbow but I like the
crossbow
But I am going to provide how do I drop the
money
I'm sorry
Do anybody got 20 leftYou need it what did
you need it for.
What did you wantNo we don't know.
We can walk to the first house and go get
some money right now what's upI'm walking.
And worst case scenario look you said you
got a pickaxe right okay
If the train if the train do come a little
bit we can take that to
Wherever it go yeahCuz I should have brought
it with me just to see how far I got.
And then besides I want to see cuz if we
find out that these trees can be cut downWe
ended up.
If not then something then if not
something's got to die and something's going
to die anyway so either way go
?
No try the tree
We needed to know this anyway so even if
it's a no it's a good thing to knowNo.
Scammed.
All right I guess it's a weaponAll right.
That's all right thoughThat's all right we
going to just come up on somebody to kill.
Cuz worst case scenario I definitely see a
house right there
And if not yeah worst case scenario the
house is all the way back there but the
worst worst case scenario is this is an
outlaw that we about to pull up on a song
This horses they're just horses thoughWe're
Gucci we're Gucci.
I don't know if they give you
RightHere comes.
Watch out alreadyPull the weapon. Hold it
pop his ass pop his ass pop his ass hell
yeah.
I meant to help you but she was too fat
Now we got fuel to get us going
If they got it
Thank you
I don't even know where the train is but if
yep
Close
Okay
???
?
Another one just died I know it didn't
Answer
There's nothing I put it on attorney
Yeah all right
Wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
Wait wait
Come on okay wait are you going to this
house you said okay babe
Is it empty yeah we already have to do
something
We just got to try to start
A lot better
Somebody got to pick up something for youI
wish.
Could just cuz the pickaxe it's more helpful
so you can get here
Extended us probably kill us on me and her
daughter
They're trying to make the bullshit
I'm so I'm not 100%?.
Okay tell me when I got to see
The big old thing is coming the big army oh
no smart smart stay back here
Let me know
All right all right all right you ready
I think
I think we just take this and just dip skip
the house
Oh never mind I didn't build it up like I
thought it would listen to it
Another one
MommyI'm leaving right now cuz we want to.
I found a new hack
To stop us from God no you screw back and
you you and you get to see them I already
know I've been doing that
All this guys got a gun oh that guy's got a
gun
I got to the bank boat though
We've been doing okay we just got to figure
out how we're going to get past that thing I
think it's cuz the the fuck the hatchet
Drop me 10 minutes I do remember me and
Carmen got it
If we both collect at the same time
She just forgot to pick it how much it is
Definitely yeah how much is the sale
I only got 25 I only got 20No we don't got
no ammo.
Here too bad to just call them down
So left
Okay let's slow down
Volume
How far are we
1000 broThat's like literally doing the run
that I'll be doing while waiting on y'all
running there and back.
And I got a bandage I'm going to be halfway
just in case she need me or you need meNo.
This way
Yeah me too cuz I've been getting a lot of
silver nuggets but weAin't may actually.
It gave you 30 for that
We got enough for a weapon nowOh well.
I want to get a weapon
?
No don't get themBut maybe we might come up
on some later.
And you can start walking the head looking
for a rocks to smash especially if you got a
pickaxe bro
Don't interact with people we just looking
for rocks broYou're up come back.
There's one coming up so keep WandaAll right
start snowing down.
And there's a rock right there so you can go
get that rock tooAll right somebody take
over.
S
And it's nothing in there
It's just that one stature
So Siri
You can grab the stuff and just dip you
don't even have to fight themWell now you
do.
They're coming from outsideHopefully I get
off Church.
What
I don't got to pick x with the record so I
couldn't have gotten it
I'm ahead of the thing it's a rock we
couldn't smash
I don't know yet all I know is we can smash
them and then we've been able to collect the
Rock
So until we have something else and I heard
that I mean I heard you say that you found a
cold in one of the rocks that we smashed so
Why
You can't handle
And then we already get that other house
over there
Yeah
There's only
One song
It was one thing
Picking up the body is nowYeah. That's what
I was like.
That
How do I get it up on the
NoI could store it.
All right I'm readyWe should be able to go
for a long time.
People moving up in rock with him today
No time zone
Anderson's house coming this weekend at the
stop keep wondering
We passing right through this shit
When you come back for it another time we
got that big new chasing that's all them s
it's night time hell no
Cuz I'm saying I still see red eyes
We're back in the storeSo. Average I thought
shit people.
Are you going to stop we need to stop in
here I'm not leaving out of here you
crazyAll them people going to come.
RightSo stock up start buying stuff sell
your shit get like think about yourself.
I know this is your stuff pick up the
picture there see I gave you too
Started with the
Send money
Baby challenge
Oh I'm stupid I let it I'll let you know for
You
We clearly could have used that for that big
thing
I got $25 but where's that onePlace where we
buy the.
Weird stuff
Over here
Imagine thinking I have 75 dollars it's
crazy
Got to come looting with usAnd here's the.
The werewolf.
Hell noThat's part of me. Yeah.
Charger period
Now
And I'm lootingI'm a looting out here. I
told you all we had two motherfucking where
it was chasing us.
A
What happened to my Dynamite
You blowing my Dynamite
No I don't know where it is
You got something on youTo drop it if I drop
you 18.
Please
I don't even know what it was for
Me I'm waiting on that change
Oh wow
Let me get that one let me get that one it's
going to give me enough to get ammoNever
mind I got that one.
Okay
There anybody you got themOne charge.
I'm just kidding stopStop.
I got 50
Minutes
Like I'm dead ass at 65
Morning timeHad to go outside and check to
make sure it ain't nothing to sit around.
Where's my horse at
Me
I ended up getting 95
Everybody come get a weapon
I got a revolver
You picked up your revolver rightIt's right
here on the floor.
Like I know you paid for twoAnd this one
doesn't work. Yeah that don't even know.
Cuz I walk down with it bro it's no way I
didn't pay for this
What
OkayYou got Emma.
I got five
I'm attaching this to theCar. Over here so
we don't accidentally make no mistakes.
And when she goes down you just grab it and
run up well we know we got to stayIt's night
time. We'll be able to get her a gun.
I'll get you in the morning Mama I ain't
going out there tonight hopefully some
people come out
He's about to a horse sitting out there
whereYou're not going to get them.
We can die from lightningRod.
E but I'm going to try and come save you at
least
Oh shitWait when did my horse get injured.
Nah Get your ass anymore
Oh man you was trying to get a bad mother
fucker
We got another what you call instead
Put it up in there
Did you have a bandage on you
I still got a weapons andAre those people
standing up.
Those people
Good time to reload
We're not putting these into what you call
it I'm selling all these guys
I don't know I don't know I'm tryingI'm
trying it.
Shut up
Holy shit
Oh you purchase that
Man I thought we was about to get paid for
that
Lol
Only got nine bullets leftMan that 500 would
have been smooth as far.
With a revived you we all would have had
good guns always had ammo
Why not
They ain't shot at me yet
You know I really got to start listening to
you when I'm playing your games
It's three of themI should have listened
okay I should have this.
Then you was right
Now
Yeah I'll play again I'll play again but
this is the last one for real for realSaid
that four times ago.
Well I'mWell I'm supposed to be Trading.
What did Jessica do
Actually I put it on the board all I wanted
to doIt.
No time soon
I'll drop you 20So you got 40.
Pickaxe and they don't go
Home
You don't got enough for that
I'm taking 10 seconds
Or a place to spend it anywhere soon so
I don't know what you doing Mama we got to
get about this town y'all
It's the same starting time bro
Ain't nobody getting a few
You have something
No more desert
Are you coming up to the buildingOkay you
might stop.
Japanese
Words
Since I started
Drop everything you just got stuckExcept for
the last cuz that's a dynamite.
No no
I know but I'm just saying in general
Okay I'm moving too so I'm just going to
pass there is winding enough action
If y'all was going to do it you already had
it late and thrown in it
Wake me up in clothes
And bothering me
BackThat bad boy has to go down.
Know
Literally nothing
Just fuelLook.
Baseball Classic
I'll just be to be but no I'll be having
legitimate complaints
ManIt's only it's two guys in here two guys
two guys.
S
Excuse me again I think we ready to go okay
One second
No I can actually
Otherwise I'm trying
I don't know how I get to choose how to
rotate it
I do not understand Roblox
Fuck it we rock like this
Song
I'm thinking about it I'm just debating if
if I see anybody else
OkayWhat time is it. It's 6:00 p.m..
And I ain't been I've been broke like I
might as well restart if we don't if we
don't go for it bro I'm going for it bro
What are you hitting them with oh my God
Yeah we just need to try and get to one
house we can and why are we not fighting
together like why we spread apart
Cuz I can help you it should be like you
welcome I whack them she whack them
Well little Pluto's already driven two
people towards himself
It's three people behind me
If two people in here if y'all make it in
hereIt's two people in here it's two people.
You blame me
I had to take a chance but it was worth the
chance well it wasn't actually worth the
chance but it could have been cuz
Like so we did see some stuff in here I'm
really doing with the team now
Today
FloweringFlowers.
Wait wait what are you coming where do you
leave wait wait wait what are you doing
That is not the plan the plan was to bring
us three horses we don't even need that
train yet
You don't need itI brought us three horses.
And had you been quicker we could have
killed Three Outlaws and all got paid
I got to take this guy to the sheriff real
quick and let's see how much money I get
paid for outlaw
35 I went out there and I killed the outlaw
and we could have got 35 each but I tried to
bring them back for everybody else and
instead they just disappeared instead of
letting us
Wait so then he don't have Osteo so now what
I need is
You got a weapon are youOkay babe.
I bet right off
Bro if somebody get on me about a horse I
hopped on when I brought child three horses
is crazy
Cuz that's where the horsesAnd that's where
the people. Y'all coming we not taking the
train.
I mean I guess we can take the train but I
wanted to just ride out and go get some
stuff like I didn't even make it to the
first house
Are you Six Bullets and killed the first guy
I bought two what the hell
Oh yeah I ain't going out tonight time I'm
trippingYeah we staying tonight.
You got a gunYou got money.
Yeah so then they definitely just kill some
I heard money
Yeah I'm just right behind youA horse.
It does take damage
Matter fact I'm getting off most and putting
you up
Cuz I'm not wasting my bullets here on these
guys that's not getting me money that's
notPut in a train.
And where we go
We really well cuz I got 48 bullets so I'm
not tripping on leaving but
What y'all going to do cuz you don't got no
weapon and we just got audio weapon so now
two of us got weapons if we can get
If we can get you an actual weapon?.
Bare minimum I think we we just gone ahead
and take the risk on dipping you buy some
bandages
Do they what's the pickaxin option here cuz
I didn't even go over there how about I
literally bought this and dipped out
Loud
Hardest daytime
I was hoping we were ready now but some only
hurry up as fast as you can
We taking this or we riding horse take it
Yeah we can actually
But I don't know if I want him oh that's the
thing
Yeah they all think about this we're
thinking
And plus that's why I wanted to see it
Somebody got to drive the boat
Exactly how I was thinking
As far as I'm loosening him though I don't
know what I'll do I just jump off and run
See I wish you had to pick upYeah.
That's the people yeah let's get themYeah
yeah yeah.
Cuz I need that 35 coins that's $70
And extra horsesAlready got him. Next.
Don't shoot the horse
Cuz I can't even get my
House okay but it's a great startI know
y'all hold me back in this game.
It's got to be bro no I see it now last time
proved it to me cuz I left without child
came back with three horses two guns and we
still managed to die I needed one person to
save me she even had a bandage on she was
picking up the bandage
Should have had 70 more points anyway I
shouldn't even tried to bring them backI'm
trying to bring them back to you. I should
have been that should have been said that's
what I should be.
Yeah
Playing selfish was the move by playing
selfish I had 48 bullets and we was good I
figured now when I'm good we're good
When y'all goodWe're not good.
That's not selfish of me I came back with
three fucking horses that you wrote off on
Exactly and I even bought you aA weapon I
mean a what you call it for the.
Oh bro give me the 10 I want it
Okay
About your sword good I'm broke good
I'm a fight stuff with me you act like
that's the end of the world bro
Oh well this first house is on fire
The first house is on fire it's right there
I'm already there I'm about to be clearing
out the first house
Whatever you will
You can do what you will
First house was emptyNo it's not.
No one
The biggest
Yeah and by the time y'all get here I'm
going to have more fuel for youOh shit.
Even worse
And I don't know where y'all went
Up this it's three bro I don't think you
understand what's out here it's Where is the
Where's the army dudesOkay when I hop up on
here and when we go.
I'm telling you now don't stopGo.
Go and it's supposed to be see what I'm
saying see what I'm saying or y'all want to
try and take them y'all want to try and jump
him
That's what I'm saying that's what I was
saying that's what I was running from
I should have killed one of them I know I
got separated I had six of them after me
But the six now I ain't even fight them I'm
still full help guys
If they do pull upYou here.
I'm still waiting to try it on something we
pulling up on some right now you can go
ahead and hit the break
We're pulling up to the Sheriff's Office
that's been taking over by zombies I see two
zombies on the outside immediately three
zombies about five zombies no less than five
times
Where's the shotgun
And into us like thatDisrespectful.
You never know
Yeah I got a lot to drop off give me a
secondWay.
What happened to that other
What the hellYeah we can't climb up with it
there.
You can goThis summer stuff.
Yeah
AttentionWhat time is it it's 12:00 a.m..
We just wait we can skip forward and just
wait
If they don't come up after us right now we
GucciAnd if they do I got my sword so stop
stop.
Somebody trying to pull upFor your sword
back.
I want to go in that church for now
It's a lot in there
It's too late now
But you should have had it out when we had
it out we needed youBut that was it for me
guys that was it.
It was nice playing with you broThis game
fun. Fuck with you later on it.
But for now I was trying to see what was in
there what's it worth it
No that big church for that one little bell
that cost 500 and I'm just saying if if the
ballistic 125
One more if the ballester cost 125 then up
something that cost 500 must go do in the
middle of the night
Bullets
Why you leaving I'm sorryBy myself.
Heck yeah
Well Nicole get back should I get me one too
no you already got one
What do I need what happened
You got 30 left after the pickupAfter the
pickaxe and you drop me 10 you
disrespectful.
Yes I would like 10 more you got the pickaxe
Cuz if I can get up to 50 like how much is
it if we break it even what we got
Each I got $20
I can get 10 so you can buy that and then
I'm going to use my last one to go bye
Cuz I just want to split the money in half
that's all I want to do it yeah I understand
completely but
Now
PacificWe'll have to come back and get more
stuff. So why we can't take the train as far
as I get this.
I ain't got to go for it but we can go
What was no point
S yeah I stopped already
You had there and I'm heading to the house
in front of us and hopefully we get
something by you out the houseYeah really we
might have to go back.
I ain't never seen these guys before
Headshots
I had to let you get it so I can save some
moneyNow hopefully these guys will work
something.
Does that mean their did it say they were
worth something
Let's head back to the thing and double
checkDid you why would you toss it in.
I didn't I said let's go back to the thing
and checkAnd you talk to all of them in
there.
You want you going to walk you know what do
what you do
It's only one in thereNo it's nothing in it.
Oh wait does that mean
Yeah
You need to go get the train and bring it up
oh yeah or should we go yeah yeah yeah yeah
Definitely checking out whatever that is I
don't care
It's 9:30 p.m.
Oh okay we're not going to be able to check
this out tonight I'm getting right out into
the railroad
With The Rock
We're heading to it wait wait
I think this is like right in front of it
right here I'm pretty sure stop
Yeah we got to go back a little bit nowBut
the pickaxe.
Something's coming from the right right now
I can't hit it cuz you're in the way
There's nothing for mine
Oh my God I'm about to dieI'm about to get
on the train and sit in the seat behind me.
I'm just trying not to die
It's 4:00 a.m.
But I'm not going to be able to go in that
house with you
Cuz I'm broke in my lifeYou feel me or no.
I'm going to have to sit this one out but
you know I'm always down to go but I just
can't
And that gets approved to me if we actually
healing or not
Yeah since it's clear out here I'm going to
pick up all the bodies you don't have to
worry about picking up the body
The house is empty
You said it's empty I see cold on the ground
valueOh.
Well you know I had to checkHad to double
check.
My health is definitely going up
I think they did this just for structure to
make it look like something
YeahI agree. Trash.
Or sell it
Yeah
All right but it's not like super important
we do that right now
Oh I can't get a job please Slow Down Slow
Down slow slow slow
Down broI know.
Go
Yeah yeah
I got them you can just stop
About to run back and go get that and want
me to run with you I got one bullet left
though so we got to is this a new house
Bro
And what time is it while we making these
rash decisionsBad decision.
At pickaxe
And nothing out back again right I'm not
tripping now
Yeah I'm just going to sit at the
What you call it an empty mustache yeah I
got you
Cuz it's actually two rocks back there we
should try to get if we can but if they were
just cold rocks I don't really care
I'm right here
LOL
Wait wait cuz it was full
I'm just trying to myself
But there's a house later and I fell off NFL
Weekend I got enough help to go but it's
night time but we could just hold down the
house if we can get in it yeah I'm going to
just text them
You did alreadyOne.
TwoExplosives chair.
All right let me see it let me see itNo you
didn't you said okay.
You don't hold this down tonightCuz I want
to go pee.
Ves
It's a big thing comingAre you hurting it
yeah.
Hey babeI knew better than to be out there
bro.
We'd have been deadAin't no way that we
defend it against him I just took all my
bullets on the last one.
Now I got to go pee
I don't care already
Yeah or no
Name
Are you talking about my little sister
The ugly ugly
We'll take it when we need it this the fuel
side where's the fuel side with though I
listen to Tank
Of us
Oh that's the good deal here yeah yeah yeah
yeah
This ladder man
I told you I'm sick of these people climbing
up on my light on my stuff no more
I'm sayingIf he jump up over this. Wait do I
got more.
Money
On my way back to sleep
He said you need to go to the store I said
well you know ahead make it soft butt right
Yeah we can bro skip passion I don't want
that second one but I don't got that I don't
got no weapons and it look like a life
Get past the big town and hit this one
More
The day before I put the day before and
everything was done on top my food was done
and you complain because I'm not there it
wasn't ready so when that being said I think
because I'm not worth it
Or I'll be stuck in that store with them
people all right we can go there he actually
got to organize something to do
Okay
Go to BMW
20 minutes away from here please
We're going to be a helper in the kitchen
meet me baby I already know I wasn't asking
you I already know the helpers the ones that
be always trying to be in the kitchen I was
just waiting for one of them all three of
them
For for
You see distracted she ain't asked yet but
they all be trying to be in the kitchen
trying to help so
Stupid let's go
Yeah let's goI'm on the train.
Yeah you don't answer that thing go why are
you stopping the tree don't got no bullets
Shoot what thingThe red guy he's behind us
cuz I'm up front.
Yeah I'mYeah I'm a prank so we got to go
push to this town and let them kill them
like we did last time.
And now knowing that this town is after the
church Town what we got to do is not fight
the church town
We got to bring the church town down here
Yeah yeah yeah go get some guns some bullets
Baby youToo young but I'm just trying to see
if somebody else so she can ask her dad.
So you not asking you offer you said you
want me to make you know you ask me if I
wanted to make you see if I can make you a
banana pudding and then I said do you still
want me to make you a banana
Maybe I'll go tomorrow okay
Okay
It's a 30 points
Are they freaking serious right nowIt went
off.
Where did it go
Nice and gray sucks wow
Store
We do
No
Good thing that we still got other RV
Kids
Look I already got
Marty got a revolver but I have to ammo I
got there I got the rifle I just messed up
cuz I bought the rifle ammo I was supposed
to buy that the ball around but now I got
both so I don't really matter I appreciate
it
Yeah if I could drop I would drop you my $9
bro
Oh that's how much money
We got two of them
No turret ammo and that's the turret am I
got right yes so that's it then
Be able to mow them boys down that's what we
need put one on the left one on the right
S
And that works every time that's why she's
goodGood Old Faithful.
I'm not going to lie I'm ready wheneverI
wish I had 10 more cents so I could have I
mean one more Cent so I can get better on
myself.
I don't either but something else
Cuz it doesn't say to pick up right and then
those sits I'm about eating I mean it near
that perfect I know I was right
Yep
And what more people more experience in the
backAnd on the side.
You we got to get a good four-person game of
this going bro what hold up is somebody
shooting at me
Oh you can't shoot from behind youRight
there all on me.
But okay but that's to be honest with you
it's cuz I didn't realize that cuz I'm
shooting at him and it lets you look
backwards but you cannot shoot backwards
Does that make sense
Open Open Door
Because you got to
Yahoo
I don't like talking
Tom
No
Do they I don't even come home but I
probably don't get that the sword
It's 30 for the sword but it ain't letting
us pick it up againAnd I like the sword too.
Right here
I'm not playing this game periodYou do know.
Why is that important for me to know
Okay but I understand completely why she
would do that
I don't do me nothing baby
I much rather just get the pistol I'm not
going to lie to you
You said I'm saying that's all that that's
all I needI'll get the rest of what I need
just from having that I like that from
Chris.
And if I had 55 I'll get the good revolver
I got 20 right now
What did you buy
Don't think I bought was one calledWhy do we
keep getting Nicole.
Cuz you don't like that walking
Was like it later
If they wanted to they could have put an
area don't buy this game
So I bought two bandages
It's
Hey baby
But I'm I'm like y'all be wanting to bandage
and stuff let's see how far we would have to
go to get some good
I'm laying down here pleaseDon't let them.
Know how far
I don't think the Thousand is far bro
Dragon shield
I don't like when people hands touch my feet
is weird your hands nasty look how pretty my
toes is and she has nothing
And we going to that house too
It's three in front of you I'm switching to
the bullet soon
Well it's only right nowIt's the Sheriff's
Office.
The problem is I can't see in here man
On this game
Yeah cuz I'm a halfway full so I'm going to
pick up this guy throw all the junk in the
yep
And I'm going to move this up to the house
Funny
You just diedHuh yeah.
What's up man that you beenHere.
Soon
I'm definitely going with the two guns I
don't care
I know you don't like the running but that
was not far from me
Where are you??
Now
Google
It turned on then I turned back up
About to go baby rainbow baby
You said you were going to do nothing today
Right here for tomorrow I'm in the middle
and then give them spoon you can come get
this phone
PleaseThank you.
Get on the boatGet on the boat hurry up
they're coming.
Come on hurry up oh my God
You know Michael Victor go get you
What happened
What's the matter
No leave
Hey everybody
No reason
I appreciate that they get it
And that's why I rock with the girl
The boys team be letting me down on every
aspect of it Asian I said it I said it
Chris that's itEven little Pinky and now.
The criminal that crap.
If we count today it's for if we don't count
it if we do cancel
Good night time
God blessing
I got 20
EverybodyMove this note move it. Let me let
me buy the gun firstly.
What's wrong
Not bad no bad news
I already started walking cuz we don't
haveBut if I was just going to use this Fuel
and find a rock.
Can I go back there
See what I'm saying
See what I'm saying like even to the point
of like coming back
Yes I don't mindThis ain't even that far
like you literally at a thousand.
I made it to 2000
No
It's crazyLet's go.
Back no
I'm already halfway there
If you came out with
$88They already sent them.
It's on the truck rememberYeah.
Yeah
Just regular ammo wait wait I don't think we
got shotgun ammo
The shotgunI don't I think that was last
game.
I don't see the shotgun that much so just
buy a shotgun
I got 38 what do you need to do a shotgun
ammo did you already get thatYeah you need
to get that.
Left give me an ammo for my rifle I'm in My
Revolver
All right
You want me to come back to you I couldn't
go back but you can wait till the next time
It's 5:00 a.m. so and I need you to pick up
Them Bodies too we need that fuel
So don't come empty-handed
Wow this is like
Straight ahead
You got to pick up right
It's raining afterReally yes.
I'm dropping your thank you RobertI dropped
it it's on the thing.
I'm ready to go
No fuel
I started walking up by with you
Where can I go100.
Wack
You have a weapon
?
So once I saw him I saw him and I was just
like all right we got people behind us I was
like excited and then I was like do do and
all six of my bullets did nothing to those
guys so then I pulled up
But that's because like I think cuz you
walked in front of me too and so like like I
miss like three bullets and then you moved
and I hit the other guy dude but then I
switch out to my shopping and the real movie
is I had a bunch of bullets reloading boys
out
For me it was a lag and then when I got done
lagging I don'tI know right.
It was so crazy though we found theHe's
trying to go bar in the house I'm not going
to have that.
Cheese stuffNow.
I don't
You getting it for me
Chips
I don't you don't have to get nothing for
all that we can just leave
Start running off at this time like I really
can't explain to youBut. It does not matter.
When we started up without the pickaxe I
really didn't care
Oh my God whatI thought.
In front of usI ain't got no gun so I can't
find me.
Oh my God no we got to run that run back to
the houseBro.
I got on call so we going to be good yeah
let's just go past it
We got to hurry are you onHurry. Hurry.
Hurry.
I killed a couple of themBut not all of them
yet.
Now all of themNo it's one more. Right here.
Meet in the money nowWe have the money for
real for real.
Went about to be night time I'm definitely
standing here overnight that's for sure
Overnight yes I'm not staying out there
overnightWhere are you at.
At the train yeah okay then I'll come all
the way back to the trainIs.
I can't see the train is
Okay fine fineOkay so I'm going back to that
house.
And I'm getting attacked
YouI know.
As far as I'm concerned it's a restart I
don't know
But if we did thatMovies about one dentist
then.
What
Because we shouldn't even died right here
bro like honestly I thought you was with me
I thought we was heading to the house
What
I was right there with you went to the train
you we worked with me like if we ended at
two completely different locations the train
is completely not the house
Are you still aliveAre you alive right now.
WhyDid you die. Why.
Are youYou're sitting around almost 300
coins and people.
We had all those benefits
In 2000 I'm like
So nothing changeBut once again cuz I'm.
I guess you can only go forward in y'all's
mindSo we're just going to go forward and
I'm just going to go home.
But I think that's stupid
Now
Hello hello
Bamboo right shorter armor
Did you not want the LeBron James I didLet
it go.
Did you pay for it
Period
YeahYeah.
Bad start cuz you
No I blame you bro it's always you it's
never me okay it could never be me
Did Arctic with the button right
Was that my phone
Is that something that I did anything else
last night
Yeah almost don't even want to check the
other building it's so late cuz I want
something that I could just keep doing
You got that911.
We should be able to as far as I'm concerned
I'm pretty sure we're able to get the cheap
gun and the cheapWhat you call it together
right.
How do I drop you change it I gave you all
the money for everything
Fell out here
Yeah yeah yeah yeah you can improves go as
far as if you already got to pick anything
Up
I'm waiting on her and stop right hereYeah.
Supposedly yeah.
Not here out there
No I don't
Know
OMG
I will take pictures
Well we got one more Zombie thing to pick up
Okay you need me to ride anything cuz I can
ride it yeah okay you get on the back
?
???
I don't know what we're going to do with
these valuable
I'll just wait until we get to that other
place thatIt's nothing on the train.
Cuz the thing is the horse always goes
forward until you press right and then it
moves over you see and then you straighten
it back out
LeftStraight.
Right straight left straight like this is me
with the left and right stick doing that
15 real quickI think we get rid of the
saddle.
I think so
Much
You have zero money okay
35 I thought we had valuable
You don't got no gun we need 20 more to get
a gun
All right but listen
Wait I'm not I'm not scared
I want it
All right
This is a good form
Get up
I'm just sit on itWhat's wrong with it.
It was outside the limit of what they wanted
to be
Unless you
I'm not trying to get on it that's the thing
I just wanted to see it okay yeah
Then I was going to get up but I'll see that
we have the other side
If they have
Free horse
What just happened to my horse
No
I lost the thingOh no.
Honey
I didn't even do anything
I don't think we were supposed to do what we
just did
Yeah
What's your horses
Never mind forget it
Right
Wait I'm on the ground
It's another big guy
Bro I got off the boat
Banana welcome
Who's me I don't know
Jazz
Play all day quietlyAre you ready.
Too late broBro. Ham.
And we could get up to 10 people up in here
I'm going to get picky on the game later
Matter of fact
Where is where is somebody with the codes
Stop the cab bro that's what they do for all
these kids
Really
Don't nothing
Urant
What you want childrenWhenever you put yours
on.
Oh these are how we get the
Phone
Name a unicorn
Kill five OutlawsYeah I got me messed up.
Now I'm ready now
I'm going to have a popcorn I have one bite
and you put it up you might not want me to
touch your mindSay that.
It's time
Grocery list
Sorry about that again
Look at you guysYou already got the money
yeah.
All right I had to do it I'm going to get
one of your stuff
No but they got the crossbow and they got
the arrows
Er
Bro what
Don't drive yet
Combiner revolver
Most not not for the revolver
How much you gotSo sad.
Song
Can you
The circleThat's like 30% cuz it's a silver
one.
Sad faceUnicorn desert.
Yo slow down
Anyways bro what the hell
I'm not on the train I'm still not on the
train I ain't caught up this all the time
Oh yeah we can sell them for a coins now
Beat
You up but now we got fuel
No no they work right
10:00 p.m.
Enough to get it
With 6,000 miles
We are ran out of people all right now
I'll be back up
Yeah I'll get back I got more help in them
and we got one more thing on the ground
right here hold up
That's another valuable item
Oh look are we going to pass up the baby
doesn't pull the people a zombie we got that
next yup I see her right there oh no I got a
crossbow so I got a crossbow too bro but we
ain't found nothing else man so we got to go
yeah
If we can we skip it but I don't
Really think that's the move but to be
honest with you we're going to use that we
need to go past just to kill enough people
just to keep going keep going please don't
stop
The climbers
All Wi-Fi upAre you. You're in the sky.
But I'm going to wait what the hell I'm
going to die
It's funny
I can see if there's
Anything
A lotWhen said do I do.
It ain't nobody in his house though
So how do I count 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
And they're all on that platform
Their shooters
No no no no no no he just caught up on me
bro
I think we could do it though that was a bad
round that was a bad round don'tHow's the
bed around don't nobody feel bad about that
we did good.
Cuz we didn't get shit
Just don't be so lameWho's playing for.
The only thing I would swap out is
gettingGetting a pickaxe.
Hey we got a pickaxe
Okay
I don't want to buy a bandage only because
they don't buy cold and somebody about to
buy a cold
We already got somebody with a pickaxeYeah
but we don't it's okay just leave it on the
floor.
We don't need another pickaxe one
Like a gun and a bandageShe already got the
bandage so now let's start let's get a gun.
ValueLet me get 15.
There's a bandage on a train
A little bit bro
What team
I am the team I still can't even get the
five coins for the gun I would like it I'm
dropping the rest of the change after I
bought it
I only got five
Yeah so wait cuz 25 might get you something
hold up let's go see you yeah pick up that
five right here
25 grab the crossbow
You might not have no bullets but we didn't
have bullets and we already got the the call
right
Yeah cuz you got the tickets
All right bet
Can you please
Come on nowReady.
Let me get the paper next time in let's goIn
front of.
You
I already know bro I'm sorry
No
This is where we got anyway she's what she
was about to go turn it in for money
Go do that like we ain't got no we can't go
nowhere we can go nowhere
Cuz you going to have some cold you can buy
cold with the money you get
And if I get what you call that I'm pretty
much going to do the same thing but I do see
some stuff look at my screen you see that
and who was with me where are they at
Stay with me we might need each other period
you take the pickaxe
Whoever this is Bali oh perfect I love you
Bobby show with them in me we're together
OK Google
That's not a rock that we could chat
And I don't think that other rock over there
You got 33 so that's at least one cold one
band bitch if you chose to go that route but
I definitely see a house over there so we're
going to get some lunch
Let's go
Got the first one you you got back them upWe
need to I need you with us.
Okay we are heading to that house let's get
to that house cuz it's dark there's going to
be a wolf that will chase me so when y'all
see that get the whoop this chasing me and
I'm going to mob straight to this house over
here
Bring the train to the house
No no you can stay until the morning cuz
we're going to we going to park up here I'm
about to die here though
All right y'all be careful coming in here
it's 3:00It's three in here.
No that's fine
That's my apologize
You left it in thereYou want to put them
both.
Beautiful
And her since she's not going to
But I'm not going to be able to get
thereI'll take the train.
I'll take the train the rest of the way
there
Goes my ride y'all
Sorry
I got to get my pickaxe by the way
Just drop it
Google
Bring it back
All rightNo. One more it's one more Amanda.
It's two more
This one right here
Okay I only have one Band-Aid left so
hopefully
I could just curious and bring this valuable
thing to the house I'm into the
That's just fuel right
What the hellNo we're not going to keep
doing that.
I take my place
I'm going to be driving
Let me know
I'm ready nowYes something to mind stop.
Let's notAnd it look like some stuff left
out here.
Can you grab her Alexa
No she didn't open his place
You going to sit down and eat it and not
drop it on the floor and if you drop it you
pick up from the insurance
Verizon
People
Stop right now
Empty
You die I don't have a dad I got to finish
it you got a message inventory
Again
There's one coming
Y'all coming around me there's nothing wrong
anymore they are disappeared
Who died
When you're back there
Try and weld it to likeThe back when you're
sitting in. That's what my big sheet of
paper was for.
That worksWhere the driver can get blocked.
With it.
It's been welded like right thereI know what
you're talking about.
Yeah yeah
A couple of times
People that don't understand
On that side
The gun in school today
Are you remember strawberries
Jolly Ranchers jawbreakers oh yeah
Wait
To ordering to or I got Walmart Plus for a
year cuz I was the spark driver right so I
actually can order groceries for free and
send it for free and I can have people you
know I can get some stuff
Oh shit
Okay I got to leave
The turkey the ham is broWhat what.
The only thing that I really got to cook on
things giving me is the turkey so I'm going
to heal y'all we got to run back
Up
I want to Stir It Up and have a problem
But I'm just we got to come back for a ride
anyway I'm not even going to stop there I'm
going to just go up here cuz I know what's
next
You see what I'm saying that's why I wanted
those werewolf guys from the night time to
follow me
Do we eat it is there infinite yes to me yet
there is
Written here
No it's no we don't got no more
Videos
I picked up right there bro
I already drop it
That's your crossbow
And I had a crossbow
No no no that's it
You don't realize you're alive or are you
done playing
Where she go?.
Cuz I've been collecting this whole time bro
I haven't done
Yet the general shop I still got a hundred
to spend we're not gone yet
No we definitely don't need no camera maybe
cuz we got to go back to that big time to
fight like we got to go save we got to say
Mariah so it's going to take like
The big gunsWe need rifles what we need bro
I got a honey.
So all I got is the Navy revolverI'm going
to I think we all go in Navy revolvers.
Cuz it's pretty strong
And that way y'all both can get maybe robots
right because whenever she does come back
hopefully cuz there's no crossbow ammo right
I'm coming back right
Do we got enough money for ammo cuz like
You drop the nine let me see let me get
thisGrab a weapon.
Grab a weapon
I got five left anybody got anything
What we working with I got 24 bullets
She got six Okay soGrab these.
Yeah
Definitely not right now bro I'm trying to
Hope one of them werewolves come out
If I do go forward though you see that right
there
Below
Right behind me with this this extra noise
So when he gets out all kicked out of
hereIt's cuz you right there with it.
Can't avoid it if you right there with it
Okay I said what I said reaction or notI got
to save a ride.
All right because I put them on the truck
and bumper truck
And this morning coming back so we're good
Baby
Who's on the controller
Why are you going forward
I understand
Sound like
Do we try and skip
Lunch
SpongeBob
First off I think it's goodYeah.
Here comes the zombie two zombies two
zombies left side
OK Google
Okay babe we go back and look
I'm still very valuable
Yeah I'm leaving the cheap stuff I'm
bringing the value books for now and I'm
just going to bring all the stuff over here
Yeah fuel too
All right next time I lost ammo cuz I died
Oh my GodBehind me.
So I'm trying to beat him up
There's one in here one zombieYou got them
on that boy ass.
Clear and we got a Band-Aid two Band-Aids
three bandaid for a Band-Aids healed up in
hereOver here.
To the side last one to the right
Sorry there are Band-Aids where I'm at are
you pool health
Interesting
You literally cannot be mad at me
No I'm saying now you be mad cuz I have to
fucking bad
OkayAmber.
All right
Yeah it was it was but but at least we found
out that like if we really try and we move
smart we can run through that town
I'm outside my room
Don't you see videos
No
Michelle on top of the horses
Bro we about to restart we didn't get no out
loud
Ly I'm not going I'm not buying the call
though
So I don't know what we going to doWe need
to just restart.
My missionIf we don't get cold we don't got
a pickaxe.
We not going to be able to kill them we not
going to be able to get far
Like what do we doCuz my only plan to kill
them right now is running over with the
train.
And we don't got no fuel to run them over
with the trainSo.
You see what I'm saying
We even hit the reread or we come up with
another plan right here right now right here
right now and I ain't got one
I bet if that's that's how we rocking that's
how we rocking in I got a shovelOr you want
to jump them.
Okay well you didn't say that at first I
mean to be honest with you I could sneak
bomb
But my mama ain't raise no home
What does that even mean
Lock your door you said what you telling me
is you don't even know what itOh wow.
Because at this point I think I didn't hit
the record
Bro and it's nothing it's absolutely nothing
And now it's night time and nothingTo me I
just kept going.
What's up guys I guess that was only looking
for the train
Like thisI told you before we got started
listening to me.
Is that a werewolf I heard
Wait so you got a gunYeah. And you was
running from The Outlaws.
Are you scaredCould never be me.
If you dieWhere is Ariah.
Oh it's going to have to leave anyway like
like I said oh oh yeah I ain't even going to
just you know what
Nothing
No I'm going to say it in your native
language no comment oh
It's not even four of us no more dummyIt's
only three of us.
Happy Christmas musicThey going to give us
the pickaxe.
They going to give me the crossbowAnd I
don't even know what Mariah like yet.
Everybody play that
Bro I know like he legitimately like get sad
if Chris do something to his Royal his brain
right again
And you got a 10% friend boost get a catch
up where is the where is the acid swamp that
you supposed to be swimming and fishing in
Or y'all just playing level one brain right
Cuz now we play brain riding away where it
got stuff that come through and you got to
stop it and if you don't kill it in time you
don't get stuff
And we be playing while we sleep cuz the
game really like thatYou don't know what I'm
talking about cuz I ain't on it.
Yeah yeah
I probably be hiding on private service
And I'll probably be hiding on private
serviceI know that's why I get the tricks
from.
Well so last time they gave us the pickaxe
this time they're going to give us the
arrows but no crossbow
What am I going to do with it nothingI'm
going to catch up or am I going to have
already found a place.
I hope so cuz I would love to loot and come
back
And does that look like something farther
thanThis little box down here.
Where's thatI'm going to drop it on the
train.
I dropped it
Please
You going to let me know or what
Dog he should be running over
On your way home
Group has been here the whole time
Here the whole time not bothered by
nobodyYeah.
I need to feed them
His name is ChicoAnd did you pick up the
rest of them. You.
KnowChicago. You want to go get them.
No cuz I know how you've always felt about
That see you've always been calling anymore
he's always been a family dog
Sweater
I learned my lesson about walking with y'all
bro every time we walk I end up dyingYeah.
I wouldn't name one successful walking to go
get something trip we done here
We going to make itI see nothing.
Fuel
What's your favorite color
I would not suggest coming to me
I ain't even know where near the
railroadHead back to the damn.
Wait wait do you got a light
You sure you don't got to wait
You did cuz we die but we did get past like
three times
Cuz I know
He got a spear
So
Teacher why you leave
Song
Shopping
You made it
BackLater.
Station
Art but options art
That areWhat you doing.
ITake on your face Pig listen to me.
Do you put are you supposed to fix this
thing
Yeah
You can't pick the same that's why it says
different answers than it said
I think it's different answer for example
You want that book
Mario
EmptyLiterally.
But looking forward to coming up to yeah
yeahOh shit.
You don't have my lightning no almost
deadWhat time is it.
2:00 a.m.
We need to find that that that baseball
thing too cuz I want to know what's in that
ball
Or Boulevard
Public closer I guess
Not even I guess for sure
So it's one hit each one we do itBut you
can't go too far ahead.
I'm injured
Doing a lot of damage are you I told you the
big kids are better
I know you said you can do it so I'm not
complaining but I'm just saying
Power cut the cheese outOh yeah.
Sure
OkaySo loot everything put it on the truck.
And take us to the town we can heal me up
when we make it to the next line
Sorry boyI can't help.
And I wish I could see a lot of valuable
stuff in the church also
And then after this this is truly my last
game
I wish I knew the barcode but I don't know
we didn't kill that guy out back
It's a guy out back that looks different
from everybody else but he has that he looks
like the town mayor or something
No definitely kill him he has the bank code
on them when you kill them
Okay then don't worry about it
See I like how the other one let you put it
on your bag so you can like at least see
what's going on while you playing
You talk about him right here in the back
him I can't see nothing is that the one guy
that's alive
That's probably him
Because it's a white paperYou see it or not.
Okay
You already got theWhat.
Some valuable stuff
Wait there's a bunch of bodies on the floor
around here you saying fuck them bodies
right there
I'll just grab my side grab them up and dip
we can put them in there later
Yeah I'm just going to go back on my phone
run
OkayAnd you looted the whole city.
Out of all the buildings
Make sure you stay in town
Oh don't take themOh man hurry up and send
me I want to go get one of those horses.
Stop
Thank you before
And I think that's what the horses are for
The trainIs for when you want to go this
way.
The horses are when you want to go the other
way
Saving me yeah we're about to go get oh we
didn't save the horses in time
Or they always say Lord something
We got to go back
Is that back
Yeah
And I see like five of them
I said I didn't know you liked them if I'd
have known you like them I would have been
offered on some stuff I'm sorry sweet
toothaches
Anything good
I don't even know what happened to my sphere
She said I put in enough money to gas I'm
going to General Store
How much is a shotgun
Okay yep you can get it cuz I have one too
but I only got 75 so I ain't getting no
records
Don't get the revolver I like them
So
You said wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
how much money you got again I got 75
So break bread
You know
I got a hundred
Metal
?
I've been doing good with that gun
I was thinking about it but the way you
talking I should just get right to limo I
could get three of these bad boys and be on
if you when it comes to rifle ammo
Why
So you say get it
This
Cuz that's all I needed it yeah I'm good
with you long enough
I'm good like I guess if you want to give me
a bandage so I can hold for me cool
Now I guess I'm on that
And if we stay here long enough we probably
good
Yeah that's more money I'm going to go
that's bandages whatever that is it's
bandages
Yeah I'm going to get this one this one's
going to be bandages I don't know what this
other one's going to be but this is going to
settle our bandages
You're blocking bandages
I need to learn something
Really three words I thought you said you
already got a revolver
Yeah you don'tYou want one.
SongAbout.
And then I got 10 more problems for thisBut
I don't got enough to actually buy.
How much elbow you got624-672.
Is this
Show
Cuz I'll be out there being scared to
shootAnd scared to like use the bandages.
That's what I'm paying I just gave you all
of it I'm choosing this one I'm going to go
get me a bandage specifically just one
bandageJust cuz I don't got one.
Here I got a bandage that's fine heal you
bandageIf we get more I get to heal me
bandage.
Dollars right now
Cuz I don't know what to spend it on I
already spent stuff I spent I got I even
bought a lantern for life then the General
Store we got the barbed wire
The size of our thing yeah yeahHow much is
it.
$20
Now
How much is it yeah
Maybe next time
I'm getting some moreHeels.
I'm sitting on three
But I'm going to drop you one I got one here
for you one heel for me and then you'll have
one here for you when he'll for me not to
help us when we go
Are we going forward or we going backwards
Bodies that you left on the floor
We're pretty decent on field plus we coming
up to two big places
As soon as we're going to go to this one
over here you want to go to this big one
And what happened to my here I still ain't
found it
But we just got to walk back right now
Me neither it's a hard decision right
We'll go hit that man what time is it
I am 6:00 p.m.
I think we go for it then
This chair
Right there
The house
Anything to bring back what they bring back
now if you got those gold plates on you I'm
like a half a foot away from the house I'll
make it
And if they do chase me right now they
stupid
Then vampire things I hope they doGood make
it back.
Yeah thank you
Is there anything else
I'm at 1:32
Back
So many more videos
I'm going to do the same thing only reason
I'm not moving cuz I'm
Your daddy overhead smokeOh snap big boy.
You
Hey I got 200 442
50 when it was when I got
It
Give me GeorgiaShut up.
So I don't know just
I think I got it in the window yeah
44 Nissan
Now
Look upYeah I give up on trying to get this
out.
Nothing interesting
Academy they don't have anything else
Do you want to leave a rifle do you have a
shotgun do you have a pistol do you have
bullets Galore like you can't find nothing
to spend money on this crazy I see a blender
glass gun how much does this cost I would
just be buying stuff bro you need me to tell
you how to spend money
And if not then give me more money it's
crazy that you can't figure out where to
spend money but you won't give me money
If I buy a bunch of barbed wire and hook up
the trainAnd that's what I do.
Bro
MattDo we have a light. I don't think on
this game.
And I got 15 leftSo.
Two more bandages
Or am I by shotgun app
Les only 15 minutes
Grabbing the cash and doing is this evening
Cash
The guys are getting strongerNo you're 15.
I'm just collecting the money but I'm not
staying for the
I'm not spending it because I'm not leaving
during dark that's for sureBut as soon as it
goes daylight.
I'm out this thing
Be back
Together
Yes I need 10
WhyAre you.
Period
Open pizza sauce
Oh
Birthday
I'm going to go explore
Sound like it's on my phone number
Mama got you intellectual dance
You got to check it
Again
You collected though
You see that
Run
Are you shootingCuz this afternoon.
Holy are you
I'm done I'm done I'm done I'm done
Yeah no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no noI've been playing since they.
You know I'm overfilled my obligation I
think I did really good as far as playing
games today
YeahYeah.
Are you done YouTube
I can dogs did you your free mode this is
the Sprint mode
The direction you want to goI mean no it
push me back.
I feel like there you almost you almost
there
Cincinnati Zoo
Never had the booty?.
We got 10 seconds for men
Right here
My little girl
My name again
Kevin
All she getting
Oh no they're taking a leave are we
taking815.
Pretty great Sunday 20 minutes
We are 879
We won like two times the rest right now you
look like cheese
Bye I'm going up this flyer so I can see the
rat up there what it is right
Help help sign up
Okay don't look at what you doing
I'm wondering you love me
Alternator
My mom wanted to know if she made me an
appointment with you babe
Have a good time daddy to do it I don't like
driving and going places
Take everybody upstairs to your room
Define
As it was in between the hours of 3 to 7:00
a.m.
Easy Joker
Got it yeah but that's it
You got to put the push the Box on
YouTube cuz it is possible to play the
gameUp inside your room right.
There you goYeah it's happening.
Like what
HappenedBut. Like like.
I'm over here reading
One ball in that week
Bye
Exclamation point
Can you tell me what I'm not about to do you
a kid I'm sorry what
No no no no no no because I don't like the
way you said that the fact you said not me
I have to show you then yes you do
Lucky compare an air in there
For you
Save me home
Yeah Google
YouTube
Oh oh I did not like that song again so many
games over
Early still having fun
Barbie
Videos
WaitIt's stomach clear dark.
I've had enoughY'all. I've had more than
enough.
I feel like y'all are allowedI feel like
you're irritating me.
The only reason I haven't kicked you up into
the room is cuz Aria would be dealing with
this headache
I'm over here readingYou are sitting right
next to each other.
I don't care I love it like this
And yes cash I didn't say you couldn't walk
around
But you know doing the things like running
in my living room when I should be done
outside and yelling
Right next to each otherI think that's a bit
much. Seeing as hell.
I don't even want no company
Excuse me
Ariel
We need to have that meeting
My bad y'all ready
Okay so what are we building today
What are you doing today are youAt HTML game
on your website.
Okay
I was trying to
Talk
You need a ham with any steps just let me
know
What I was trying to say was that baby girl
was trying to make
A video game in an HTML page today could you
explain her some pretty cool options for
video games or a video game ideas and get
some inspiration started
Absolutely HTML base game that's a really
funny like a simple interactive Story game
A little more game like they're simple
browser games like making it clicker game or
a little character that moves around the
spring those can be done just a little bit
of HTML and a little bit of scripture there
are also a lot of free templates and
tutorials out there that she could use so
she needs to starting point I can point you
resources as well
Yeah no problem at all if you or she needs
more ideas down the line just let me know
it's always fun to have someone get started
Me personally I want to create an adventure
game
Today
You thinking of doing it in a wet friendly
way you could use something like a job for
game engine favor or just doing more simply
with HTML CSS and a bit of vanilla
JavaScript it can be as minimal or something
ain't no eating on my baby
Absolutely
Send it to her phone
Yeah no worries at all you can definitely
keep it all about building that game it's
having a good time with it if you need any
other tips or just want to bounce ideas
around
I think of one kind of like RuneScape of
course no it doesn't have to be a MMORPG or
even on the level of RuneScape I was more so
thinking on the lines of Shining Force
actually
That's really cool Direction so kind of like
a classic
Bowl or turn based Adventure is more like
shining for you to the elementWhere the full
blown mmosphere.
That's definitely doable on smaller scale
and can still be super fun to make you could
map out a simple Bridge so yeah
That sounds like a great project and
definitely something you can chip away at
piece
Just holding shoes
Yeah absolutely it's definitely a fun idea
and you can really run with it but whenever
you're ready to dive in if you need to help
along the way
Let me know and we can bring some more
detailsFigure out the next step together.
No no no no no no no no all right so the
first HTML game that I want to make I found
out exactly what I want to make I want to
make an exact replica of battle Tetris I
want to be able to battle my daughter on
Tetris we ain't spending this out to 10
million people concurring uses and nothing
like that I want to be able to battle Aria I
want Aria to be able to battle me and I want
Aria to be able to battle the AI agent we
train that's it
Are that sounds like a really cool and very
focused idea so basically you're looking to
create a head-to-head battle Tetris kind of
Clone where you and Aria and maybe a train
AI agent throwing us the mix for some fun
that's definitely doable it keeps it nice
and personal you won't have to worry about
scaling it up to a huge muscle area so yeah
let's go for it we can definitely figure out
how to put together and touch this battle
set up in HTML and JavaScript and we'll keep
it too plus
Let's make it happen all right cool let's
let's get it let's get this project
scaffolded out let's go ahead and create a
project structure tree and the way that I do
want this the the main focus that I do want
this to be is it should be similar to
Like a candy crush kind of thing so that you
go in and level one is well different modes
you know I would like to have a Candy Crush
mode where we had different Tetris pieces
and we had so many different ones and we had
to clear it perfectly on the way down and
then I was thinking of like a you know the
classical little Tetris mode
Let's just start with what we got and create
a nice little PRD to get us going
Out nice girl
One bowl for plastic Tetris battles and one
for that candy crushed out clearing and will
keep it all nice and lean so you can play
against Aria or the AI
Let's get that structure mapped out and
we'll go from there
So now is where I would go in and then and
it's actually crazy to see build them from
the beginning but now that's where I would
ask the agent to show me a visual it's
understanding of what I just explained to it
right and then I have to check the
implementation idea just to see if it even
makes sense cuz sometimes the AI
hallucinates and if it hallucinates in this
part of the project then the whole project
is doomed to it circle cycle Loop did we'll
just be doing the same stuff for a few
months when I should be able to knock out a
project like this in a few prompts
And what about for you what are you doing
When you say working on your website I made
specifically what are you working on your
website
And it was supposed to be
That makes perfect sense
Of what you envision the end to look like
Go upstairs have you sent out the full
vision of what you expect the end to look
like
It's been like describe that to meIn ever a
great detail.
Talking to my wife
Wasn'tIt.
Yeah let me check the picture
What are you doing
Right and have you sketched out with the end
pigeon for yours look like no I want to hear
it
To do something like artInteresting.
All right we're leaving it lost track of
exactly what we were saying
One
Me too
You're not playingBe quiet.
Okay so please
A
Spanish
Arigato I got a blaster
And the goal isn't just being able
To do itIt's been able to do it. Sounds.
Issue.
This is going on
Okay
What's a gameAnd website actually.
Did you get it to break it down small enough
to where it's going to fit in that Discord
message or are you going to get on the
computer and copy it from the chat DVD
Cuz it just has to go to the agent doesn't
matter how you send it
You're so rated and if you send it from the
computer you can send a longer message I'm
just saying
I'm just sayingBigger problem bigger
project.
I bet you I can getThe agents from this
computer.
To talk to the agents from that computer
Disability
You know that if you come close if you come
close to money for like 6:00 or something
And tell him we get today will tell him we
went today so we going tomorrow
What are you doing that you can't go right
now
No I'm talking to you
All right goodnight
Yeah cuz I'm trying to send as many with as
possible
Hey tell Lauren I said tell your mama I said
what's up
A.m.
Here I was thinking I was going to get a win
check no maybe later
It's okay I realizedNobody.
Nobody know
Just messing with you
So I'm going to do a wolf a line in the
frontHey.
Google
Save system the hunt and team system do you
notified login
Minecraft birthday cake wonder how many
characters can be there
In there how many characters can I put until
it's blocks off the message on Discord
Show you what God left and work at MissAnd
fat.
I'll be back
No no
Message that I was trying to keep from the
agent I Was preparing a message and I was
trying to paste the rest of it but I deleted
it
And I don't even remember
What the hell
We needed to put on our guests
I'm not doing itNo I was so happy.
Even though
Oh yeah we're we're even on food now because
I say good that mean you're not ready for
Texas sizes so when you eat your half a
Patty meal you just leave the rest of it for
me
Online
Next year
And leave out that animal's lifestyle room
and it's Central to the world to travel in
the building and it's safe you can hunt
It's parked learning about well now
10 agents
Did they ever get that Hawaiian Punch mess
out the kitchen or am I going to go in there
and go off on kids
Not going
Buy something cashCash.
DevastatedIf you are.
Education did that Hawaiian Punch mess that
I asked you how to clean up early
Oh that's right my girl right got me
My messagesUnderstand.
Bring me my water back
Yeah that's my waterYes.
Because maybe this is the Discord about
runningDid you try hashtag help.
Did that work did you try hashtag help
anywhere
If nothing happens
So you didn't want it right you going for
the small
So you don't want itThey told me you wanted
it.
Wait wait
Yeah get back if you keep doing it
Halo2. Whenever to the east light all the
candles.
I guess already bad enough I have to deal
with all this noise around me I can't stop
noise around me right
But people bumping into me is really wildAnd
I really can stop all this noise around
because I ain't none of this noise around me
my noise.
Look on my screenWait let me get back to
you.
Oh that's why I can'tThat's why. You be
calling me a traitor.
Hey Google
I'm the Debbie Diner I'm just sorry sad but
I'm the Eeyore but I didn't ask for none of
this
I was in my cave comfortable bro I don't
know what happened
It's still not working
It's so oh you are too painful when youMan
yep.
Oh I got a spider followingI know how to get
this fighting.
Everything
Ohio lottery tickets
Come over by my hands don't hesitation
Abide water
I know what we need to think aboutAnd I got
one.
Everything on this County
Why do I keep drinking or what it can make
it to me
Because I'm back
Nothing what do you want me to buy food or
waterWeekend.
Are you about to work with me hey this is
not number seven
GoGet the type.
It's 5:10Okay I'll be back.
Okay
What did I do blog wanted to do KC I have it
I still have it
It did it start that disc for aboutGo to
agent. You type in help.
You didn't do it
Did you eat do you need a jokerOh well.
I'll have cheeseI like my cheese chicken.
By time link
The early accident
S
At work
Okay thank youAnd did agent 8 respond in the
Discord too.
And eight you shouldn't have to send a
message in Discord
The Discord by Just Got Started seven
Seven
I don't see why not
Send a message
You haven't messaged agent
Did you send the message station ain't using
message agent
I'm asking you a question did you use did
you message AJ using messages that's all I
ask
Okay but that was all ask
Ing
I'm going to buy something and it even shows
you what part of the message got sent if
your full message didn't get sent you know
you sent it two big message
I'm just letting you know
I have a water
I put water in the water
So I got Spencer
Put it on the show okay
We got two birthday kids in a bandageOne
good we're all cute.
I hate when the time pleaseAll about.
Sleep
Ing with you
Coldwater
I know y'all just trying to play the game
but my kids are literally cold and right now
And listen how quiet it is
No I don't have to be nearly as what I've
already suggested to y'all to go up to the
kids room with this and y'all's loudness
But y'all care not what I suggest
Don't even mean it like a punishment I meant
it like like y'all could have took the game
up there with y'all and everything
Yeah that'sI know something else to school.
Ain't nothing worse than waking up in your
ass on the floor and you got protection
And you can't get out of your leg your leg
your leg raise like you got to say your legs
falling asleep
Bad been thereYou ever played Tetris.
Ever played picturesMama you ever played
Tetris.
Huh you ever played centers
Yeah long time ago but what's the difference
between well it's a difference
I was going to say between that and Candy
Crush but
No no no I can make like a Tetris like Candy
Crush where you got like so many pieces to
get to the bottom yeah I want to do that
And then just make like a bunch of
challenges just to get people something to
do it'll be for free on my website no add no
matter
You can tell me daddy didn't do that you
can't tell me he did three both eyes
But I never saw him in the number one's when
I was like
Cuz I was at like you you just you just
passing I'm passing with astonishing colors
You have to tell yourself stuff like that
you have to tell yourself stuff like that
when you're not number one for real
Life
Enough to lose it back to back to back
But it is a good time pass though I give
them that
So I just started making a Tetris game when
I just started talking to Aria and Carmen
right
And this is what I love about AII'm already
done. I'll.
Send a picture ofBurger and I can't buy baby
but. I mean I don't want to.
And they expensiveBut I don't know what.
Kids are eating.
Hey what's going on
Yeah that's it I'm just figuring the day was
going to figure it out
Yeah everybody else
A bless I'm so blessed to have a sister
This is what I'm saying nowTetris is
completed.
I'm out of quick there though I got to find
it quickie quickie button here's the quickie
quickie button
I got to scroll why is it coming here it
should open another page or something
You can play
Tell me what I need
I'm not doing through the time that's the AI
I made a AI computer to you know a project
wouldn't be cool if I didn't add AI to it
some kind of way so I built a train I'm
trying to train the AI agent to play like us
and
I'm thinking right now in this very moment
as I'm talking to you that a cool feature
would be for it to learn from how we play
So that so that that influence is how it
plays in overtime as we get better it'll get
better against us to the point where we
can't beat it
No it's always going to be against the AI
agent mode and you'll just remember the day
where you used to be able to beat it
That's the other mode I haven't worked on
that I just did theTetris that's the tetris.
I owe you why what happened cuz I fell
asleep
But not know if it's still up here
Wait what's the question again did you do
because I say it's not a good idea for us to
tow
And people going tow the car
From wherever wherever he's doing right but
not knowing it's the car actually there
You might want to know it if it's up there
that's why I'm saying because I know they
can tow it they can tow it we don't have to
be there
We don't have to be there so that's why I
was trying to tell her like I feel like it's
a waste of toll trying to
Tow it you know what I'm saying and not know
it's up thereBut you can also have them take
pictures.
And send it to your phone
I feel like I know this way so
I'll be sleeping at 3:00We sleeping at where
it's at.
That's what I'm saying
I need to go and see if it's still up there
she said it's been up there the last time
she went you know
LikeYou.
Answer you played it what do you think it's
like cuz it's not about the plan again it's
about to improving the game part I wanted to
be good I want to host another website
what's wrong with it how do I get it better
I know exactly how to get there
Mama how do you know me so well
She wanted some Whataburger so I'm going to
split my Whataburger with her then you don't
have to say you buying everybody with a
burger cuz I'm splitting my Whataburger than
my mom about me and you don't have to get
them rich girls nothing cuz we don't like
them I'm talking about Kiki and katira
specifically not not all the girls in the
house we love all y'all really really I
really do that's why I haven't personally
tried to kick you out although I could have
just kicked you out or kicked you up the
game and then I would have made you get out
there
That is going to just a regular double
cheese no lettuce no tomatoes no nothing
You're going to hit youAgain.
It's cuz if I got if I go up there and get
it right you not going to ask me for a bite
of my whatever
I know so why am I getting any kind of
attitude
Now you're welcome there you ain't getting a
piece of my way back
I'll let space hard drive
Kind of suck look
I don't like this yeah
You're hungry you're tired you got to go
rest
Go to your dentist safely
Yeah
Oh my God I see the idea
Oh yeah
I'm sorry babe
I don't want nothing but ketchup
They want to double cheeseburger a double
cheeseburger and just ketchup no lettuce no
tomatoes none of that
Just the Redwood cheese
If you can have the fries I don't care if
they cry
You want it if it comes with it you want it
you can
This onePlease.
Her do you get the double cheeseburger when
you get the meal cuz she said that she don't
want her drink or whatever
Yeah I'm going to take the drink
But I don't really want none of the burger
that's all that you can have your burger
I'll take the frogs
Trying to check me out the price right there
I heard I heard the movie
She was trying to cut me out the fries
I felt it I felt it used 50 of your sentence
It scrubs on my bed bro
I see I didn't see nobody eating there but
I'm sure they were I got to get him
outPosition.
It's a village
She's eating chips over there so I figure I
don't care about nowhere else but my bed
yeah
That's my bed I don't eat on my I don't eat
on my bedLike I don't.
And that's not been something I just made up
now you know I've been saying that since I
was sleeping in my room
I'm not splitting with her you splitting
your portion with herI don't like her like
that.
I'm going to end up getting me for half my
bad
I'm going to get a third of my own Burger
Represent tomorrowI don't know what they're
going to do for dinner tonight cuz they
started on this room.
Be with church chicken and some like maybe
yeah
You got to get the cooking nowFlying in mind
if you like it I've been cooking.
What you see now
The only reason I started
Eating on now on me it's cuz everybody up in
now but I've been here
Sally I ain't embarrassed that's happening
man maybe I give me a lady I start actually
eating right but till then
I'm just trying to survive man yeah I want
to do it
RightMaybe.
I just want a break from it and I can
understand I'm not the only one
LikeEverybody in their room right now.
That mean they wanted a break from itThat's.
People
Siri is late
Just one
I'm trying
Robot
Baby
He's so cute
Ariana
Sorry I'm running around she got there today
I still love you just like I still love this
dancing
Comma all right so if I ask you to help me
to fill out food stamps and you know all of
my life
Celebrities
And I wouldn't doubt it
I don't got no like romance
Is it
Ever forgive me but I can never forget to
and never forget it and I can stay not to do
me the way that dummy yeah
And I will never do nobody do what they
didSo.
Thank you
Give me about being a blessingGrits I did
everything I did.
And it wasn't good enoughI got to live with
that feeling that feeling that I'll never
find somebody to find me to be good enough.
So I cut you out to the chase I beat you out
to the punch I abandoning you out before you
abandon me
MyselfFeedback if my boots will take all of
that.
You said itEx value.
Kristoff doing something going to Michigan I
don't know what I've been able to do
anything about it
I'm dead ignore Mom wants to talk to him
before she come visit us
Tell Lauren mom if she want to talk to me
give me her number then trying to talk to my
mom
Trailer
They want me to talk to the pan and so I was
like I'll talk to the parent I want to talk
to the lady anyway she fine and she said she
don't talk to you like that what I want to
talk
I didn't put you in the middle of that
My mama said what's up
Rihanna
I'm trying to figure out this car
procrastinate and in that good stuff out
I can't smoke wants the video I got to have
bubble gum to chew it and slams and walk at
the same time
Good night angel it's nice chatting up with
you I'm going to call you back later
Daddy video
Yeah a different y'all generationY'all
generation was on another step.
Okay cuzI couldn't know.
I could never be as proactive as you
And I wonder cuz if y'all's parents were
stronger than y'allOh God.
I'm not safe for children
Ninja Turtles
Okay
ThatI'm just here.
Day 2
Cara
For somebody on day oneBelow the dinosaurs.
YesPlease.
It's really really happy
Wedding
I'm not in India
Excellent
Hello
Ship
Google
Chicago movie theater please
Stop talking
I think he's crying inside
I love it
Yeah I just got up the phone I just got done
watching the video too no I don't look that
bad it look pretty easy and it look like the
tools required either I have her Kiki have
What's the dish
Like I said between what me and Kiki have
cuz I also have
A lot of sockets like I got just a box full
of sockets
To take it down you saying do it down there
Yeah
Sir
I have to peace before 12:30 I don't think
you understand how good that is I've already
watched the video and I already have a plan
in place for the tools and everything like
that's a lot that we just cover it all since
the last time
Was going to direction that I was going on
the side of the road like you wanted to
cross
MoneyI feel.
We are
Here I understand that I don't even have
plans on going like at first now now I'm
doing but
I'm going to go I will be there drinking how
can I guarantee you on what time I'm going
to get up to start going though but I will
be there
Before Thanksgiving is overAnd on time for
the dinner.
No I said I was going to come tonight I'm
going to come later but that's the plan
really because if I got it cuz my plan
tonight
And then put the piece on in the morningLike
both sound good to me but leaving right now
does not sound good to me.
Cuz I just got up like I just I ain't just
get up but I just got up and out and moved
around and I ain't even want to do that I
didn't but I did and I want you to see that
that I'm not trying to be difficult
I even got that I left the house before
Good babe don't tell me that look don't tell
me that you don't keep doing good I'm doing
so good
Right now right now I'm just going to focus
on what I got to do cuz if I focus on that
ended that's even shaking yeah you mean I
could have came down there she didn't come
down there everybody
Right right
Now
You ain't got lie I know it's been about 30
31 32 years and it's okay
I understand though I'm not I would be able
to help you but I ain't really talking to
you anymore like we're not we're not it's
shaky between us and I'm not trying to argue
with you
Yep
Still for
I know right
How do you happen to Kentucky just got here
today
Yeah it's frozen
Literally an hour ago
Bring my puppy attack on the flash
Wednesday
But you expect rain
It's just doing too much that day
Avatar
26136-72 103
I definitely did it I'm starting to get to
that point
Right yeah I can't do I wish I had it in you
That'sOkay.
I'm going to cost me
You said something about Black Eyed Peas you
said you was going to pick up some black
eyed peas and put them on that's what I'm
saying I'm thinking the end thing is that's
why I'm thinking she doesn't need so much
time because if her plan is to just you know
like
My princess even the mail that she made last
year and I'm not complaining when I say it
It was not the it was not
It wasn't what it wasn't like a fool
Christmas I mean it wasn't a Fool's dinner
like I mean I'm not I'm really not insulting
it but it's it was at the end of the day it
wasn't the pound cake the cheesecake just
the sweet potato pie pumpkin pie you know
what I mean like
Empire
Movies
If I don't if we don't go down there tonight
then I got to fix it tonight
Thinking about dinner if we don't go
Today
Tacos game tomorrow I got enchiladas without
trying to do stuffing to go get stuck as an
enchilada for you though
Thank you babe
Leaving
Appreciate what's the baby
Just starting to see what we wait for
themWhen I start getting irritated.
And your procrastination is
Mine
It wasn't the plan that
Who get it man
We're not working on your time
Don't know she will have no green it will be
out of Dreams
Need something
Aria
Don't jump on YouTube give me a call and
trust me
You drivingOr you riding. Driving a ride.
Nobody just want you I will make it with the
children
Baby
Orange playing Ariel
Free Batman
Imaginext
I better kill you you
Know whatSomebody can still Sonic videos.
Forest
Hello at the reindeerStop.
Please
Yeah that's
That's like experim away
What's the weather today
What do you need and go do what you need cuz
it's clearly something you need to do for
your website and I'm not understanding what
it is
I have no clue right now
Yes
Anyways
He download so much
CountEverybody.
Grand Theft Auto
Peterson cheating with a bomb
S to the store with my mommy and call me
Back I'm trying to kill you
Here do not mean you come in here and
annoying me
I wouldn't talk about you
Talking to the person that came in the
silent room starting to be loud
S yes
Please
Chucky
Password
Okay well everybody walking out anyway I got
no business but the distance right situation
but I'm not what you doing I'm not
Everybody in there had something to do with
something in there
But I will
Come upThank you.
And when we playing dead trials
When are we playing dead trails
Google English
English
In fact now that I'm thinking about it they
didn't even ask me if it's okay
I'm going to leave out with meWhat if I had
plans.
What if I had a date with Lauren's momAnd
Carmen.
I thought you was supposed to be putting me
in love with my mama
Jokes
Mama got like Perkins
And this is what they left me with
Chad this is what they left me withThis is
why I can't have a successful screen. I have
to be irritated bye.
KitterlingsI want to do dumbass arguing.
It wouldn't be so bad if they were chill but
they're not chill though like they just loud
for no reason running around the house and
it'll be like some of them be purposely
trying to irritate me what's up Carmen
No you bet
I don't even want this little piece I got
over here I'm going to give it to the
doggyIt's not a play but you can take it.
Got to throw that away for me
Oh Lord here comes the loud one
Why not
I don't want it
Arrow is your mama or notIs your mama doing
lot.
I'm pretty sureIt's supposed to never mind
I'm just going to put it on your money.
Yeah
Siri stupid me I was wondering if
If Roblox
Couldn't even be respectful to me last night
I'll be doing too much for that but
disrespecting even be a thought
And yetConstantly. Why should I do the most
people they want to do the minimum.
I couldn't even get an apology after I told
her I was older apology it's one thing if
you didn't notice it's another not to give a
fuck we could both play that I don't give a
fuck game
I'm notHey her mama. Didn't tell me tomorrow
call me.
YesterdayArkansas right now what.
Okay
I ain't trying to listen to motherfucking
name the same stadium but right I'm chilling
bro if you see right now I got the agents
running
Or you can't see it cuz you probably see me
right now but
Let's switch it back to that I got the
agents running and they're they're beginning
to
They're beginning to implement the
acknowledgment LoopProtocol.
And that's such a beautiful thingI'm trying
to see cuz apparently I don't know what
button I'm trying to press this button.
I got you let me see if I can turn it up a
little bitTell me is this better is this too
much.
Probably way too much on
All right full blast we'll go all right this
is for a blast or maybe I got to goThis all
the way right here.
I don't like yellingOkay babe okay babe okay
babe.
And so I got the I got the agents going
right now
I've been good I might have to I might have
to change my notification thing though
I've been I ain't never stop that's that's
one thing for sure that's one thing about me
you know I ain't never going to stop and now
they're never going to stop if I keep on
going I keep on pushing I can possibly get
this to efficient development
So right now what I have them beginning to
do is to go through my 75 my $75 GitHub
repos cuz what
Cuz what turns out give me one second cuz
I'm not going to argue and yell over you hey
hey I don't never have nobody in my stream
it's the one time a day I'm going to ask
y'all not right now
I appreciate that cuz I just don't want to
yell over you I want to be able to have a
nice little conversation
All right and so I have them going through
75 GitHub repos cuz it turns out that after
sending cuz I have the project scanner which
does an AST run of directory right and even
the nested director is inside of the
director and so you can use that to turn
your projects into a Json Snapchat I mean a
snapshot read and understand to get a quick
context of the project so then I said it up
with the GitHub API to be able to go through
my GitHub now you see I got the multi-agent
orchestration going on so I had them analyze
each one of my repos turns out I've only
made 33 projects even though I got 75 repos
right I've been circling the drain around
the same thing agent tools death tools web
scrapers Discord butts lots of lots of
Discord but I think I got
Destination with the Discord butts but
that's another story no let me take that
back actually the project that I have done
the most is this project that I'm that you
see right now that's one thing my very first
project was this project I'm so proud of me
I never gave up
I made this I started this project before I
started making a trading robot I gave up on
the trading robot came back to this
And then I finish the trading robot that's
in here too we actually made some money off
of some predictions made this morning now
I don't know if I'm going to keep doing that
though becauseIt just doesn't give me the
same.
It's not the same
You know you know and I ain't even trying to
brag I'm just I guess I'm kind of I am kind
of trying to brag man I'm kind of proud cuz
I feel like I've come a long way
I remember when I was pasting the messages
and mind you
Before I started code I ain't know how to
code
And I still barely understand how to code
but I know enough to get by I tell you that
much I speak Spanish if there's a way of
saying that in cold and I speak Spanglish
Actually I bet you they probably call that
pseudo code
Oh man
I'm proud to hear that you ever be screaming
you know how to hop on and watch cuz I'm not
really vocal too much so I do appreciate
when people do come by and just peek in
A lot of what I use this stream for is just
building in public cuz you know I'm in love
Like I said I'm liking an echo chamber with
my agents you know what I mean like in
solitude cuz in the real world there's
nobody to talk to about these things nobody
is going to understand that I was running
the agents autonomously overnight one of the
agents deleted my EMB file and the cicd
stopped them from being able to push my
Robin Hood password to the
To theGitHub repo.
However it wasn't good enough to stop them
from sending my Discord bot and my GitHub
token to the to the Envy I mean to get up
right right
I was extra careful with my bank pen all
right but I wasn't extra careful with these
API tokens and it spit I had spent almost
two days with BFG cleaner trying to find
that stuff
But we found it cuz like I told you I'd
never give up
But imagine if my Robin Hood would have got
posted manBro way.
And that just brought to the light that I
needed
I still have no clue how to get Hub I mean
how to get
Forgot deleted I still have no clue how to
get ignore got deleted and I need to go back
and go through the whole project to see
because I'm pretty sure there are some
Jason's that I forgot about or some some
Some kind of configuration valves that I
forgot about somewhere along the way this
probably getting pushed now
Cuz all I did was just ask the agents the
gun ahead and make us a new get ignore
I probably should well I know what I'll do
now I'll probably go through the the
timeline
On the get ignore and then
Update with more but like at this point I'm
not going to lie to you man I'm I've started
to add so much like pre-commit hooks that
like push into my own branches starting to
become a hassle in the irritation and I
don't know if that's a good thing
Or a bad thing but I know it's a bottleneck
I know it frustrates me
I know this
So what you been up to anyway man yeah what
you been up to
YeahYeah.
I ain't going to lie you ain't never lying
and I and I'm trying to balance between
system hardening like clean up tasks kind of
like technical debt and expansion into new
domains I know that we're supposed to love
the
I know we're supposed toI should be just
relaxing I still got car work to do.
I know we're supposed to like the Nitty
Gritty you know making sure we have our our
typing Center test coverage is all good and
integration X into n and all that I get it
I'm cool and I'm with it it's worth it but
The fun part of coding is seeing what else
can be done
I want to see the hiccups and I know like
right now I'm not I'm like I'm talking to
you all calm but I'm actually crossing my
fingers cuz I literally just set the agents
loose on my GitHub account
The way I've explained it to the the agents
is that they have been the face of this
project and that was in a that was in an
attempt to get them to understand that this
was not just code into like stop trying to
create agents the agents that I was talking
about are the cursor agents and we're trying
to orchestrate them but I didn't know at the
time how to say it like that that seems to
be the biggest thing like I really didn't
know exactly what I wanted but as as the
project goes it seems at points I know
exactly what I want
Until I sort of get towards the goal post
and the field goal moves 10 ft farther
Cuz
When I first started this project I would
have just been happy to see the agents
talking to each other
But now now I need them to talk and not I
need them to talk and follow protocols along
the way I need them to talk and understand
the context and and be able to you see what
I'm saying
You see what I'm saying like man
When I knew it was a way and I just couldn't
figure it out like what man and the
breakthroughs the breakthroughs are like
boss battles I know you have had the feeling
of beating a video game Boss and and back
And and back when we was younger we used to
do this thing where we all had one
controller was playing with so only one
person could play at a time and it didn't
really matter cuz they didn't have no good
two player co-op games back in the day so
the one player games that we used to play
would be like Donkey Kong Mario party I mean
Mario Just Mario I'm tripping and whoever
whoever will go against the boss
Would just be going at it right and you be
passing the controller passing the
controller until somebody finally hit the
right combinations and finally got that dub
and that that feeling right there man it's
the same feeling I get when I Implement a
new feature or I fix an error that has been
holding me up for
N n is I'm not even talking about like
little import ears I'm talking about the
kind of errors that you can't even ask the
agent to fix no more cuz you've explained it
10 times and it still doesn't understand you
don't went to
You don't went online on Google and had to
search exactly what this code mean and and
and you had to put it together to get it cuz
it's cuz the agent can't see so it didn't
understand that you were telling it that it
didn't understand for whatever reason that
it needed the candy Library as well as the
CV to do the edge detection
Or or what really I've started to notice
that there they lack is the ability to
realize how things
Really interact likeHow it all connects.
I don't think they ever get the big picture
Or the small picture or one of the
twoThey're missing something.
Yes I'm not oh if if I if they would just
grab me with unlimited context for just
To see get just give me an hourJust a smooth
out I might actually finish a project.
I might actually close the loop guys we
might actually hit a public face and feature
did I tell you we got websites now
Yeah we got websites man put my web hat onIf
the agents give me a second to talk I'll
show you I'll show you.
Rock it we're taking over the computer
they're not that important
Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeahWe got it.
We got put that pet projects right they're
pet projectsYeah we are sworn.
That excited like my first little place away
I see don't embarrass me
Okay wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
before I embarrassed myself right
It might not work let's throw that out there
let's throw that out there
Psychologie
System this one basically was looking for
patterns inside the Bible because I wanted
people to know exactly how fun math was I
get the Monte Carlo simulations from my
background knowledge in poker because I work
at a poker house and just the numbers
numbers have always been interested in
interesting to me and I got a guy at work
that's been talking to me so much about
these things whipped up a quick little
website just to pull up so with something
like this you can actually pull up the
actual
And Gematria analysis of the Bible and so
what they do is they basically look for
patterns
And it the agents taking my control in my
mouth but it basically proves supposedly
proves that the Bible couldn't have been
wrote by humans it's just
Mathematically not that
And so what we did do is we took the
original Hebrew Bible right from the
Right from the Jewish scholar website I
forget which
But this was my attempt to make a website
based off of somebody else's idea so don't
think I'm amazing enough to come up with
this this is like I made something for
someone else and that's why I call it a pet
project yeah
Just making sure everything
Making sure everything works you know making
sure we're not making sure we do what we do
you all the time cuz this design is not my
design I had a more biblical design but my
boy Charlie made this design let's see let's
see number two let's see what I got baby
girl out there making right this is baby
girl work
Boom okay she ain't got no post she ain't
got no blog post okay but she do got a
playlist
What she got for us does it work
Okay okay okay
All right all right all right we going we
going to get on look today is coding day so
check us tomorrow we going to have we going
to have our first post on there okay I
promise all right next website was working
on which mine this is the one that I made it
to like showcase myself
Just just my projects I probably don't have
a blog post eitherThe cool thing about all
of these websites.
The Swarm was able to make them post them
update them fix any problems that we have
except for apparently this developer tools
link issue I'm going to see if I can get
them to fix that I noticed it okay okay
Okay okay you eat somebody's trying to send
you a message no that's to 60
68 or 6 to youYou already have that.
Oh it didn't paste it yet I should have
waited LOLYep see there it is.
Said agent 3 all right so if I can get over
here in time I can press you
And then we just take you up here cuz I
don't need it over here
Bingo all right that's what happens when you
have a frail pie Ido GUI system but the cool
thing is that you can like this and there's
nothing between nothing no different between
this and the command line the only thing is
they didn't have the command line when I
started working on this and at this point
I like this thing I got banned from GitHub
third parties for spam cuz I sent the agents
loose and I guess overnight they did 600
something commits worth of they did 600
commits like that that's just what they did
you know and so
I've been Outcast from the development World
they won't let me get third party apps so
that that inspired me to go over my GitHub
create a new job account and
Start porting my projects over turns out I
had 75 so I was like man
How many times I make the same project I
don't know what gave me that hunch but I
knew I was doing it because I always do that
I'm the type of person that like I could be
talking to you and circle back around and
talk about the same thing I was already
talking to you about
So I know that I know that I'll do that as
far as like creating projects
And it might not even be it might not even
be that I didn't notice it might be that I
just tried to do it better this time or I
wanted to attempt a different way of doing
it or I wanted to revisit it as a as a
For an incense I know for a fact I went back
and did the meter over
And I tried to turn it into a full-blown
streaming app until I
Was working on the design of the new GUI
before hooking up the back into the front
end I realized that I could just create
plugins and add them to OBS and I think that
that's a
Think that that's a better solution than
creating my own
Streaming application from scratch I
constantly talk with blaze you know that's
one of my favorite streamers about
HowJust because you can do something doesn't
mean that you should.
Like for instance just because I can go to
sleep on stream doesn't mean I should keep
getting caught falling asleep
But I work till my batteries out so I have I
make no regrets you know I'll be here 24/77
Even when the kids are over for Thanksgiving
and they're in here making too much noise
and I'm yelling and having a fit
I'm going to be online and y'all just have
to bear with itAnd I'll talk about me later
but I don't care.
And call me with you each otherwise
All right oh no get back to the unless it's
okay and so this website I'm trying to ring
this website back from
I ain't going to lie I'm now looking at the
to do KC website and I'm feeling like
It's just not giving an aesthetically
pleasing Vibe so probably going to redo it
but I did go through and try to like
basically describe the project or and myself
And so that's what I explained to them I
haven't gone through and
I haven't gone through yet to try to
implement the blogging feature that makes
them sound like me so
That once that does get online I think that
I think that this will be a nice little
automation system
So far I've been trying to have sessions
with my agents to see what
Like what are we offering here like what
what is easy for us over here and so far I'm
not going to lie to you like things that
come easy to the storm
Test coverage things that come easy doc
strings in it files like basic stuff and so
what it can do is if you have a list of prds
and like if you already have the plan and
you know what you want then the Swarm is
perfect if you don't know what you want then
the Swarm is perfect cuz they can brainstorm
like I want to say that
Like when I when I become when I get the
point when I get to a point where I'm
actually trying to Market it I would try to
Market it as the vibe coders dream cuz
I'm fixing to play Roblox with the kids as
this project ports over my repos
And I know because I had them brainstorm the
idea while I played with the kids yesterday
And that's pretty much it that's
All I got rocking around one thing that I
have been trying to do is I've been trying
to learn how to read more code right so
that's always my biggest thing to prove to
myself that I know what I'm doing and
Gotten to a point where I'm able to write
small ScriptsI'm able to.
Read way better than I am able to write and
so now that I've grasp and understanding of
reading I'm trying to get a grasp of writing
and I feel like because when I read
The code
When I read the code it's more like an
investigation I'm putting together a bunch
of context clues I feel like to be a reader
of code you have to understand the syntax
But like a
A surface level understanding and as far as
being able to actually write the code
yourself
Now that's an understanding that I still
wouldn't even be able to Bear up to the
grass
I can't even say that I can't even say I
couldn't begin to grasp but I can't wait to
die further in and become more of an expert
on the subject I can't wait until the day
where I'm writing functions before the AI
can finish thinking in my head right like I
might not be able to type it out as fast but
I'm already working it out cuz like
Right now I considered a traffic light and
piece together in pseudocode how I would
begin to write a traffic
Something to throw with themNot offense.
That's the second oneBring me my magnet back
so I can make the third one and loud and
clear for you.
Cuz I want you to be able to know that the
next time I throw that you'll have to go
upstairs
Bring it back and I know you hear me please
don't make me repeat myself again
If I have to throw it again cuz y'all got
too loud I have to feel like I have to fight
over y'all to talk then you have to go
upstairs cuz this is my room not yours
Remember what happens when you sit there
silentYou want to remember what happens when
you sit there silently instead of
responding.
Then what do you need to doNow you need to
say yes sir. Okay.
MineAnd don't forget cuz you don't want to
go upstairs.
And since you just have to go to the
restroom you might want to go do that
Oh that's an accurate about to pull on meI
understand.
I don't even remember what I'm saying
anymore
Duplicates found
That sounds bad but
That sounds bad but a majority of that was
BNB because I didn't know anything
And you don't know what you don't know I'm
stupid enough to push my BNB to the I know I
could just push the requirements text at the
time all right but we're looking back at all
my old projects so what I'm not going to do
is like getting mad at myself for the things
that I was I was doing at the time
Whatever it may have beenI was able to.
Wonder when the kids are coming back so we
can play the railroad gameAnd never coming
back.
All right so I just read one of the agents
and basically it's saying that I am I've hit
my limit on
I guess I've hit the limit on theGitHub API
it's one of the apis that we're using.
To access GitHub I know one's like
graphSomething I want to say graph CV.
Bugaboo laptop I got an ideaIt's going to
get you the most.
In advance
So much work
You got to be real careful with that laptop
PlusGot to be real careful with that laptop
it's old.
It's not as young as we used to beThis is
fragile. But it worked pretty good.
Press the home button when you get the
chance
Checking on them
Road
And sell them now
Cuz I'm just going to go back and forth with
you
You know the passwordThe same as the. Yep.
I would appreciate if you didn't say that on
the screen
Did you login
I didn't say press home I said press power
And there's something on the other sideOf
the computer bro.
I'm talking to the guy has left y'all can
proceed talkingPerfect time.
Hey
Road so that little orange thing at the
bottom back leftThis morning.
How do you put the only things up online
That's not it if you click it and I said
it's not it would be anything going to be
It's not that it is the second one oh my God
YouConsider the Manila ones Orange.
And the orange one word
Because I can't see what you clicking from
over here and you should know what orange is
I'm guessing the red one it's the one that
looks too close to Orange right
NowThe Mozilla fire. Ball and it ain't no
internet right now now we need already.
You know how to do that
No no no no no no no no no no
Born l i n u x
U x
Type robot money songIt was the first option
about the repair.
That's right
Mother
Restaurant
Google Superman
Hey babyGet off my baby go girl I'm sorry.
Little
If anybody told me you still have that pizza
there
You still have wingsAnd. I have a chicken.
It's not a lot but it's still with some
chicken and bacon quesadilla and and a steak
and baking quesadilla that I bought from
work it's just like two slices all of that
is on the deep freezer I just bought it
downstairs so if you're hungry
Tonight
No not really
Not really
I knew you'd see that
Period
No I haven't started
You ended up getting up here
You like the black pizza now
I understand like that movie
Plan but I was just kidding cuz they just
got back actually so hopefully that means
mission accomplished
No I didn't look for it
RightI seen the video is like I said it
looked like it's a reach.
But it definitely looks changeable and it's
it's right there it's one clip so
Right well I'm well
At least I don't belong
To get yourself tell him I was out there
twerking originally
Yeah
Right but I didn't break away tooI'm not
okay.
DrivingInstructor.
I'm not going to be sleeping with my
daughter negative needed to nothing
It's available football
Speak Japanese
Forgot about you
Not really old is just the way I got it set
up when you want to do something with you
set it up
But after I set it up run just like the
other games
I ain't giving up my mouth
Happy birthday
Man
I did not want to let us know
Wow there's no way to do it
Time to stop and send it on TV
Mother
It's working
Okay
I have to be homie she's notGood forever.
Activities
Didn't even get a Robot ChickenYou didn't
ask.
If I could have just did all that does that
mean Roblox as a website too you can just go
to work.com and download everything
Is way easierWay faster.
I love you
Stop it
Not a baby
All the pictures
But no limitQuestion mark.
Show me Instagram
Pictures
Oh no I'm
Going to go sorry I'm not even visitFor
today.
I'm
I just look at dogs
Hey you got a new number
I like how when I when she came here the
other day what we've been asking what the
kids to do for about Good hours so she I
imagine just hopped on
I had to tell her maybe not you you ain't
pulling out one box out there
I just wouldn't buy it I don't know I don't
know
Maybe I got too much faith in court
I like to play the blame game today finally
pick somebody to pick up and we all just
jumped that person
MamaNo she literally said with the phone on
speaker I told you not to get married.
Damn safe I don't think I was supposed to
hear that you know what that asshole said
again I told her get married I said
But I'm likeShe did that. On the wedding
page.
PeriodI have no clue.
Exactly so I'll take your shoes
I'm not going to lie I think I like seven
bags of trash
All the trash in the trash I took out the
trash
0700 why they say that's fair I know right
Thanksgiving with y'all tomorrow can I
please have give me a sandwich please
You got to go plates on you I can bring it
to go play them
Well then I guessWe're going to last year's
plan.
Ninja challenge
I got to be at work
Family
Even areas Airlines
Come here
We didn't take Spanish
All the money is that I have left after the
pickaxe is right here
Now I'm going to go see if I can find a
pickaxe I'm in a rock
Yeah that way we don't got to buy gas bro
Are we going to get luckyAnd we got lucky.
Got one call out of thatNo it's better than
nothing.
So put the
Put the paper in the in Chicago then come on
Well after you finish getting all your stuff
I mean
You're getting a pickaxe too I got to
pickaxeYou got it.
I literally said I hadHe said I had a big
head.
I just died
Period
Batman Robin
Orientation
I am
Thank you
Ariel
You can't play it
EverydayI want to see what I see.
Number
Are you dancing
Okay this songI will try to make it to the
house with the train.
So we can get some food
I should have just been patient that's what
I should have did I just don't like waiting
A pickaxe againGoing to give you the rest of
the cash.
And over here too
I want to get them
Channel 5 News
The rainbow song
Yeah but she's not doing that
Song
I'm so sorry
That's when I get into
I'm not
Fat
I just want something I'll be ready whenever
I still got to pick up the papers anyway
we're not ready
I like the revolver as a choice
Obviously
We got pregnant
Hopefully they shoot up something when we
get some money
Okay the train is ready to go
Pictures
And it might not be money but at least it's
fuel
Price
Getting hit broYeah bro Ryan do something
you're standing still watching you.
Don't give us no money for these guys
Now it's upstairs
I think I'll go down
You can go to that house I'm just checking
these rocks to see if they're rocks
Yeah
Bro what you don't see the houseIt's right
here.
House is cleared we just got to come in and
look
No it's not clear somethingIt's two guys.
Nothing I just got everything was not
addingIt now and it's perfect cuz it's night
time too so.
Let's get on that train and keep making our
way
Are you driving her
I was emptying my sack we could haveAll
right I'm going to.
So we going to bedI don't know.
I don't know what the movie is right now
When you got the gun
NoKill the other guys.
All right so no pickaxeNo pickaxe for sure.
We just we both did yeah okay
I guess this time we both get a gun cuz we
got to defend ourselves
Or maybe I get the gun and you get the
pickaxe if they got the can you click the
butt
But let me turn like the red movie got to
keep doing it okay we do cuz that's the
money we don't get money from chilling with
yourself we got to stop being scared and
kill the stuff cuz that's how we get money
to get more stuff and that's how we got the
money then we started
The other stuff to protect the trains like
get money is good in this game
That's why I be trying to just go like like
that's why I'm not trying to waste money on
the the coal and stuff especially if we can
get those things like right off the whip
But it don't always work out like that
soThat's the thing but when it does it works
out perfectly.
Hello
No of course nothing not going to do it's
like that but they got the crossbow the
crossbow's pretty good but we don't got no
arrows to go with the crossbow we do got the
sword I guess the swords made decent
How much is thatAll right watch movie. Okay
I'll move it.
RightIt's 30 each so I wonder which ones
it's harder.
Is this one's 32But. I'm going with the gun.
Let me see how much she done is cheap gun35
cheap bullets.
50 that'll leave me with 20$20 that'll leave
you with $40 cuz you also have 20.
And then with 40 you can still get that and
a bandage that works out let's do that
That's on you Mama
We just really just trying to make it past
this first love will do so here's the money
See if I can jump ahead and find somebody to
Get killed real quick yeah yeah so we can
have some more people well actually I'm
awake but just try not to
Cuz it should be I already got the paper so
all you got to do is get it and then hop on
the train and we can go
And you already get the bandage 2 or
It's the third dark we could just stay but
if it don't turn dark then we delete
Because if it turned dark is better to just
stay hereAnd it's already. 2:00.
My picture
Yep it's the disappearing vampire guys
Take these bodies back to the thingCome on
what the heck you.
He's dead nowSo now we go back.
Yeah yeah we just went and get that far from
the base so we just going to go backThat's
going to help us to get ammo or something.
And then it's going to be dark time so run
back like try and speed
Cuz it's about to be dark and they about to
start chasing after us it's literallyWhat
time is. It it is.
9:00 so you night time comingNo don't get on
the train go back to the Village.
They going to come overnight and they got
people in the village that's going to shoot
plus we can restock
You got to bandage so if you get hit on the
way just healed up and keep running
But you should make it as long as you make
it to where they start shooting a gunfire we
going to be okay
That's what I'm talking about like it's
always a guyWhat do you mean he right who's
right where.
I was like what are you talking about all
you got to do is run towards the base
I'm already into townSo.
Nobody even on you broI came back.
That put me a 45 just to start and we
probably going to find more when we look
around here
That one's going to be for fuel that works
perfectCuz I'm I don't want to hook up.
Can you pick this guy up and it's not
letting me pick this upNever mind I got him.
All right with 45
Yeah we did do good you can start heading to
the train right now
I wasn't able to get you a gun I mean ammo
but I was able to get you a gun
So we'll be able to get more guns later
Let's head back to the what you call it oh
wait wait there's people out here are these
guys the valuable ones or noNo.
No well we still need them so we I'm taking
them for fuel
That's what I'm saying I'm thinking we might
even just get used to just stay in the first
day to collect some bodies
On where the next town is or how we doing
this next town here in the meantime take
this
Yeah the trains right there I just
If y'all doing stuff on that stairs they
could get you hurt bro
As long as you understand England to the
hospital
Okay
Again
It's a note 8 times already
Did you grab it
Yeah
Well if are we driving
We can if you want but we got to go past it
first go past it firstGo past it first go
past it first.
All them Zombies going to start coming and
attacking the thing
Cuz you stop right here oh my God bro bro
you know this
Something
Please tell me there's somebody's in the
city somewhere cuz we need money we have
none
I don't know what the move is right now
It's a hard run right now
Need money we should have tried to kill some
of those guys but as we shouldn't have
stopped so close like
Old town was right there bro you know that
was the Mega town right
We only got five coins I don't got no trade
in point I guess we got to
Hold upWe're lucky Maybe. Maybe we might be
blessed.
And it's no pickaxe
In heaven
That stuff we don't got no money for none of
that
I mean I can't sell it either but I'm just
saying I can't do nothing with it
And we don't got no bullets you got any
money on youYeah and how many bullets you
got left.
Yeah I'm definitely not going onI didn't
have no money for bullets I gave you a gun
bro.
At 7:00
I'm thinking maybe we go check and see if we
can find that what you call it body so we
can get some ammo
Cuz I don't really want to go forward like
that's a lot of loot we're leaving behind
But I mean in the same breath ain't no point
in going back if we going to die
So it's really on you I don't really care
So we going to run back and I go back to the
mega City
I ain't no point in just going back for that
Dad one body that just died so if that's the
case we might as well just head forward
The only reason to go back is cuz the city
if we're not going back for the city we
could just go for it ain't no even point in
debate
No it's not the same city but we're passing
through
Is it somebody behind us
You're looking this morning
That's unfortunate
Yeah I don't got no more bullets for this
big boy
Yes but I know I asked you if it was a guy
bro
It don't matter he's about to kill me
How much do you need for the pickaxe
You need 30 from meYou need 30 for me to get
the pickaxe.
You don't got no moneyOh you don't need 30
to get it do you.
I'm like what
Boy games that you only need 10 for meSo
won't do it.
I'm fineIt gets me 15 again. Let's get it.
I thank you
Secret Garden
I'm just waiting on you I'm just standing
out here just in case of zombie might come
Right nothing cost less than 10 so
If you started
Looking at me I'm still waiting on you
I thought you was already coming otherwise
I'd have just kept walking to the place
Yep
I should have just cameOut.
But it's all right though cuz hopefully we
get a good pickaxe place
Oh my God
I wonder what that isAlways so rock.
A rock all the way out here with nothing on
it you disrespectful monkeys
Still no good rocks
NoIf they don't got the little shiny things
sticking out of them and you can't pick
them.
I want to see Natalie YouTube
Characters
You die
All right
Hopefully did you have a bandage on youNot
this around that was the last round huh. All
right.
Happy birthday to me
StillPeriod.
Boy appointment
New girl
The girls
Cuz I just told him bring my tail back home
Hi
It'sWelcome.
Honey what happened to Dallas
Stop playing or what
At the garage
Is it
No no no no just tell me the account after
you count for the mental man
A songThat's it. Including. You're not
playing.
You're not playingThen why would you sit
back there just sit and stupid like you
know.
Everybody action
Sorry bad enough y'all didn't dip for 2
hours and you said you was just walking down
the street
Are y'all ready
It's fine
Waiting on the last one to walk in
Drugs
No we want to be gravity today
Oh well
Oh you went ahead
Almost got him I'm sorry
Thank youYeah but she had one.
So we got something to talk
To everybody
Why why are you just sitting there though
you're not going to help them
I'm not talking about you I'm talking about
the person sitting downThat's the extra
Firepower we could have to help us kill
these zombies.
That's how people die
Okay
There's somebody there
It's a guy on top of apartment
Answer me it's gone and nowBro is gone it's
not my return.
Where you at
Home
What you can jump upPolice got to get
attacked by acid fucking with you.
What should
Like it I had a gun
It's like for my 301 and say hello then I
left my shit
?
JJ and KK
I really don't know what you're supposed to
do with the road throw it in the fire
Ball
We're going like in your hair
And I want
It
Try
How did you fall off the screen you didn't
say anything
No nothing no commentYou just watch yourself
slide off right by the worst place to
follow.
For sure
It's smart if you had to go over there in
the dark against the zombie horde we always
do
It's a guy coming right now
Exactly
What her down cuz there's two vampiresI just
did.
Hit himDriving the train.
Driving to the state drive it to the city
If we can make it into the city we safe
Hopefully we got enough valuables to buy
bandages
So you hear the people with money that's the
people you need to revive first
Bro what are you doing can you revive
somebody
Doing bro
No you didn't you the man be wondering what
you be doing
And right behind there is carbon right
behind hers Ariel
No Ariel at the top of the list I still not
she fell off the train she had
Yeah ArizonaBecause the only way you can
move.
ForwardAnd look like some shit dude.
Don't trust in innocent face
It's your game
Interesting interesting 888You sir.
If you're going to annoy them you're going
to annoy meAnd y'all could do.
It's not that I'm stuckI got to exit that's
it for.
If I was stuck it wouldn't let me do
anythingWe need a fire.
BallBe there and be there.
Don't wait till somebody else up in
Aaron didn't join everybody got to leave
again bro
Oke waste time on it
Yesterday
StillWorking over there.
It's not that hard what she shouldn't have
left actually
Five people
$20
Waiting on everybody
Nope I figured we needed like three more
drives to figure it out
Let me know when y'all figure it all out
To the 30s
Is everybody in there
Get in
No don't press anything
Right
Now
Don't let me go on fire
No for real and people leave I'm done it's
my last one that's fucking crazy
15 minutes to start the game as wellFor us
to get to the first place and die.
No
I'm sorryThank you.
Did you grab your Bandit
You already did that for you bye
Did anybody call
Someone
Away
I'm singing song
You want to leave early you got to walkI'm
trying for the group.
You don't want to be part of the group I'm
going to be early be part of the early Squad
Why does my gun keep shootingKeeps like
randomly shooting.
Everybody already leftSo.
Yes if you don't only have the train station
you could just
Make it far no probably not they just left
stuff before they catch up with us
I took the trainSong.
It was nothing at the house already got
everything
I'm about to walk in the afternoon
That workBut let me change the way it looks
like.
Yahoo
I can't pick up that Barrel
My wife blow meWhat does Sonic.
I'm going out there to the Outlaws
I only have
Pink 15%
Peppa Pig Peppa PigPeppa.
Pig
Coming back with nothing but weapons
Minecraft songsWho got some food.
Cuz I just told you I got for you
OkayKarma going to drive Carmen going to
drop the train. Let me hurry up.
Bro
Google call Mom
I keep going one way to see if the train
tracks are that way but then I don't see it
There's nothing around me
Always do dropping on you you're not on a
train
Hold up
Yeah
You're all the way out to the left or the
right that was a dumb decision from the
beginning
That we got to figure out where you are
And you haven't even tried walking the other
way like you just kept walking the wrong way
and kept going
And you ain't seen no house no nothing no
shapes no nothing period
Big Town
Broke where I ain't doing nothing tonight
Why do you not see a village full of Fire
That far to the left Carmen look to the left
I wish you would have told me already did I
got all the weapons all the stuff fromI
thought we got a little bit of oil.
Cuz I put the OutlawsWith the Outlaws that I
got in the tank. Is Aria in there.
By the timeThe fuck I asked you if you was
here.
Bye
We need are you to go pick that
Italian stuff on trip I just dropped it
because I had to my stuff was don't work
It's me
Of courseI'm coming to the big city.
Basketball
Somebody Jason
And then you're not even drawing them
straight to me I could have that one shot
before all of them guys bro
Okay
Well
Happy
Well they killed me just don't be so
stupidAll he must say. Yeah I know you're
welcome.
I don't know why y'all pointed out like that
that's on y'all
I got two benches
Guessing the ball watch
There's a room full of zombies if you guys
are your schedule too yeah
And they don't know where the transport
y'all oh snapNothing.
No
Back I've killed like 30 Zombies bro what if
y'all been doing
I found the baseballWhat's the code.
What's the code
Yeah I guess and we lost the other
Or maybe she wanted to turn it in herself I
don't know cuz I ain't hear nothingI was
just kind of waiting.
Eat
If you just wanted to do it you could see it
there bro I'm not going to sit here and play
with you
It's night time now
Right but I still want to finish losing and
I want to check out what's in that
ballThat's why I did all the shooting over
there.
The problem is it's about to be night time
nowSo I'm just going to chill in town.
Bar are you looking areas coming to the bar
looking area
If you come to the left Carmen we can smack
that guy come to the left so he goes through
the doorHe wants to play stupid.
Volleyball fieldWhat did you say.
If you got a bandage there's someone on the
train
Bro don't talk about what nobody
Right now
Now who was with me an expert gun
Hopefully we got some bullets nowCuz like I
said I was the problem I have full I have a
gun but no bullets.
Oh actuallyThat mean we can shoot off the
back of that thing.
No I'm going to come back I just have to
empty my sack I know how much stuff was up
there I accidentally used to go to the holy
thing
No not only waterThe valuable holy thing. I
accidentally used it.
That's why I was asking like what was people
doing like did we get this both open no no
Cuz she gave me the code but it wasn't
enough numbers so let me know when the code
All right bro
I'm looking around too I'm hoping that it's
somewhere on the ground
It has to be on the left side of all this
stuff because I was on the I was on the
other side and I when I tell you I cleared
out everything that was damn near on that
left side of this whole area
ArrivingSo it's got to be over there on the
other side.
Probably on like stuck in the ground or some
shit
So be on the road
I don't I have that don't know those things
I don't know I was just about to try and
guessing
And I'm about to go look around again hope I
don't know I guess we're going to have to
give up on the bank but we're going to do
that another time
Damn bro
Oh let me let me help simplify it bro
OK Google
To grow upPhone trying to pick me up.
I just didn't feel like explaining to you
that the computer or the agents were running
themselves
And I was using cursor ID to do it
So there's four of them that you could see
but there's actually eight of them
And they're yeah we waiting on I'm talking
to somebody
But right now we're just playingOh I'm
hopping off since y'all don't see this
thing.
That's a what yeah I know why we're not
going there
Bro why would IWho said so.
Okay
No it's a gold plate over here bro
You haven't seen wait wait how did you die
bro cuz y'all trying to get the money
You can hear you bro why you
Over there last one to run in the building
mad cuz the people on the outside of the
building
That block
Oh no are they going to stop bro I'm out of
there bro I tried I tried I tried all right
I believe you
Oh I definitely blame me
Bro we never go get them back no no no no no
no no no
It's the baseball for me
On the house she got the Note
She ran the train pass the people almost got
everybody on the train cute I jumped off
beforehand
What was alive
And then you going to put everybody on the
bus and then just take us cuz we just get
the big town so
Said
Like the whole reason I've been trying to
hit this damn town is to figure out the
Vault I finally had the weapon to take out
the people at the town and they lost the
bank
Okay come open my back I got two guns in
there come help me and then come here
whatever
It should be sorry
Period
Where's your box I don't see it anymore okay
move me move this time should be somewhere
over here or anything back okay
I'll see you againYou can use.
Yes that's why I got it already night time
Earl at the computer
How dumb does that sound
Today and waiting
I think that was stupid
Now just that but I always be like remind me
that
Inventory
Who got the pickaxe you going to hit that
cold
Sometimes she died
Please
Just going to go get the what you call it
and come back
Home
I tried to get it I couldn't get itNothing
to try and die.
No but we got to get on the train we got to
go
Oh yeah go go go go
Go execute leaving I don't know how to say
it
RelaxationDo you lying what.
Let meKnow.
The valuable onesSo the the vampire ones
that are killing that's why I'm standing
outside I'm stacking his bodies up.
You trade him
Roses the dog is not the same thing
Think you can try something
Like I said the vampire corpses are worth 15
each that's like big money in this game
Yep the other ones we use is fuel
Hopefully that got good stuff at the general
store today
And we need to clean up it's a whole bunch
of stuff that laying around I guess we need
to get rid of it
Or do something with
We about to come and save Ariel soon
All right what we looking like as far as
Moneyball
And I ain't even started like selling stuff
on the truck yet
Oh y'all already sold the stuff on the truck
Rest is good cuz I'll be put in words like
yeah I don't even understandHuh.
How much you gotAnd said that's the movie.
Yeah I just need the gunsmithGot the gun.
Yeah life is easier with the gun like I'm
not going to lie to you
It's a white clear with the two holes in it
Look real quick
If I know how frustrating that should
beOkay. Yeah I use that shit.
Where was itI didn't look under.
Big enough
Christmas
And it's a house down there if you sitting
bored it's the house right outside the place
so I could be loose
That's on you you supposed to be looking
around
It's about to be night time again yeahI'm
stacking up.
Ain't bad to stay up here
Well we got to kill people around
She's really just making me looking for a
good yeah yeah like this guy this guy going
to get you some moneyHe's a nice little 20
piece.
You better pick up them off the ground like
me
Might have got a dick
So I think about that no one improved
I just want to whoop out here
Period
CallMe all right.
Ariel
Dang you beat me to it
I was lucky because like she said she was
going back
I understand it was going to take a minute
it ain't no point in just sitting around
doing nothing
Like by the time she get back please tell me
y'all have spent all your money and y'all
ready to go only person we should be waiting
on is Ariel cuz she ain't had time to get
ready
By the time Ariel ready
You need a gun
The ones
No no no no no no no no no no no no no get
her
Get her no get herOh well I had extra I had
extra guns I was just going to give her one
but forget it it's cool with me.
Nothing it doesn't matterI had an extra gun
I was just going to give her one of my life
for.
Huh
I think ArianaGrande.
Why did you wait wait wait wait no after you
said you bought it already the deal was off
the table so I don't know why you did that
I would be but somebody keep knocking down
my sheetsCuz I know it was done and then
somebody come knock him off.
Who
No yeah
I get money areaI ain't giving it dirty. All
right boom.
Here take this bro you can have this one
Bro what the heckAll right. Bro.
I'm not
Ready to go
Well you know we thought we was going to
leave
What we couldn't have been left when
everybody wasn't ready
Right what is you getting mad for cuz we
prepped before we leave
Oh they definitely are and it's the big boys
I'm going inside I'm going inside they got
me fucked up
Everybody
Uncle bigGot to be flicker than that.
Oh you know that
Thing
It was right behind me I'm sorry I got
enough money to save it I got the money
Bro just killed meThere's no more.
Pluto stay up there why would you jump down
YeahYeah everybody bro.
All right now
Why are you picking up my box
EsNo yeah different.
Yeah differentDifferently different. And of
course she said paper.
I'm over here right here
Are you above the girl I thank you you're
welcome I already know I had like four of
them on me now mind you understand that the
wolf is 20 of Pop all four wolves are gone
and I'm still dead
Yeah I just wanted to say that I just wanted
to say that
I'm so stupid
I understand I understand
Oh everybody has an excuse nowUntil I get my
80.
Homie
Back and my guns and my bullets I'm solo
download
You got 30 on my seat I'm almost willing to
be a team player again I'm almost
There we almost there
You know what oh yes
Because everybody just took all the woods
that I just had all those words
I would even die half my bulletsI got all
the guns.
No I'm good all I need to doThis.
Getting bullets now
WhoYes.
No you need to buy yourself ammo
You got to be self-sufficient mama I just
gave you a weapon I don't need nothing from
you I'm just fucking with him I'm very
self-sufficient in this game I'll be getting
my bullets after I steal that first 60 from
your boys
What do you mean you ain't got no Navy
revolved around
All these turrets we got on the back ain't
nobody pick up no tearing ammo don't worry I
got the bullets I'll tell you one thing
don't come in here and try to act like you
contribute into the cars now bye ugly
YesYes I want to leave before night time
again bro somebody need to be keeping track
of time.
Ain't nobody talking about Papa
Explaining to me
Facebook
No I've literally just killed it
I literally just killed it
Oh my God shut up
You got to do itI don't know what you're
talking about.
You
All right everybody yeah I'm going to go
check my vampire
Process will be due
At work
Ariana Grande
ZombiesInteresting.
ArielAre you here identify you ain't
supposed to do that yesterday when you left
that mess.
Alright somebody
Wait wait
A minute charger
House coming up on the left
Don't forget to
Okay
Yeah
Up at the top yeah that's where I want to
put mine
Is this spot was not good I just didn't want
to say nothing
No sort of I got an empty myself first
Can't do it I can't put it up there I can't
get stuff
I'm going to load it up just tell me when
you're ready to goI'm ready.
EverybodyWait she's not ready.
That's why it's not working
She didn't listen she still going
On
EmpireBut we had no choice we almost lost a
whole turret.
We got enough weapons and stuff on here to
where we should be able to kill a vampire
bro
And that's justIt's about to kill me.
And take advantage
It's like they going crazy it's a lot of
them
Well no more no
Thanks
One of them on top of the on top of the
train we was trying to but when we was
moving it wouldn't let me and then the thing
fell off the back and by the time I picked
it up off the floor
OK Google
And then I died she went thereI'm going to
go jump over to my package but we can buy me
a pack of shit.
Come on timeI died and somebody wouldn't
even need.
Thank you it was nice
And she's dead so if she's deadI don't think
you're dead.
Jersey who got a baby
We got to hurry them before night time
I just got your windowOK Google.
Cara
Pictures
No
Got a vacation that you will singPills.
Fucking water
No he did
I don't know
Somebody in the bed or do I should have made
it
If you're up with the sugar before
Dude I'm not packing
I wouldn't want to either it's too big
I whispered it out of respect for you
I want to just put it to the sideBut at
least we don't like Roblox out their
computer now.
No this is actually a good runAt last
little.
That last little hiccup was just something
that happened in this game cuz you know soon
as it gets dark it's about to go down
It's frustrating when I look up and I'm
shooting on my bullets and people not even
at the controller
Oh no that wasn't you that's when you shot
that was area she was the one that left us
all stranded on the train
While she was over there eating pizza
pockets
Now when I tell the story about what
happened when the Ops came
Air ran out the back
I ain't no better I already went to the
fight over run up in there and say hey what
happened
Now you plan still to bring oneThing.
Oh you finally stacked up enough to get
Something back in the day
Okay buddy
So what time does that mean we leaving
Your carJust ride in your car.
I just need to know if I need to mentally
prepared to drive today tonight
Or if I need to mentally prepare to you know
wake up when I normally wake up and get up
and drive
It's got to be an early bird Mama start at
12:00
At 10:00
I did too
ArielI'm not going to hold you I think
everybody left I would not sit there and
wait if I were you.
There ain't nobody even tell you good cuz
you left you left out the back
I'm just playing it was a good match I hope
you got some point
No don't look at that I'm dead I'm gone
I'm out of there I was out of there when I
looked up and I saw you and left usFix it.
No but I'm not kidding I genuinely had funI
really like that game.
I know you're not playing stupid brainwide
again I know you didn't go right back to
thisAriel come on now.
You only got 21 billionLet me know like.
Hey Uncle how old a couple of dollars you
know I'm saying Niecy everyday used to do
when I was when I was growing up you let me
hold a couple dollars
Can I be one of those kind of Uncle
I just want to know who did that
I feel like it was the person behind me
That was the direction I heard it come from
I got to goTo the country.
Can't afford to you like that
Three Square meals a dayMake that food
pyramid.
Actually you're supposed to eat every 4 to 6
hours
Did all together
Portion control
Honestly clocked out at this point if I lay
down I'm gone
No no no they close at 2:00 or 3:00
A.m.
Why you keep saying emo
Is there is no notice on when we got to go
It's going to be on BP time so like
everything going to be all right then all of
a sudden a major Rush going to kick in and
everybody going to be trying to hit the hay
like we got and ain't been
Preparing for this for the last 2 weeksAnd
I'm here for it.
I'm not new to this I'm True to this I'm
doing this my whole life
Bro like likeYou want to thin straw bro.
One and a half
One and a half so when I say I need a one
and a half of these four into the things
what you think one
Not half not half of it
Yep that's it for meI'm going to sleep. Let
me rephrase that.
Going to try to go to sleep
Aria
I had a reason when I first called you how
about let me think
It was a good question
But I honestly can't remember him
But it's something to do it
Nothing nothingI'm going to take a nap.
CuzI don't know when but. Y'all need to be
prepared to leave.
I would go withThree pairs of clothes.
You don't got options
Nobody was down
Here
You will think it would stop right cuz I
seen video where they took a hole to get
For her if she if she poking out of
herselfIt don't matter to her.
Mama
Well I mean if you want to watch people say
People make tonight
Temperature
That's awesome
Open up our little things so
Then he got on something
No no okay
8 minutes
Rihanna
The older oneThe older one.
One
Monica
Oh and
Midnight performanceTalking.
About
Stop
How much come here I need some help
And then also I have another question
The sweet potatoes aren't cookedI wasn't
talking about.
Mac and cheese
Free properties
Don't
Let me do we talk
About it period
I couldn't have sex
I love this how you trying to read tomorrow
Cuz
Amazon 10:20 in my nap in 30For one train or
two we're all going.
But I tried to block one so you can add you
or something with you Daddy cancel my whole
subscription and then it went back up
RosalinaA. That's the one who look like
Elsa. Look at this.
Candy
Desp
Acito
Mason
Wait Kayla did you press on start again
Hello
This one
I don't know how to do this room
As I have
Wait how come
Amazon
And the first time he ever came in here he
was like waiting a HD HD going on in hereAnd
get out of there.
Itchy
Really don't the more I be thinking about it
like I don't understand why I'm going down
there
Don't know
Really
Beautiful
It's not make myself good I'm not making
myself go next year that's the last year me
doing all this
Thank you for accepting care I'm about to
get to care about it
Nobody will give a fucking feel some picture
if I was having an event in the country the
IP the only one there
And don't nobody give me my flowers today
I know who goes to the upstairs
15 in the door ain't I advertisement
Know what happened
A new idea when I wasn't even planning on
going
In my car
Problems I'm like what did I really do this
for
I mean I said hello again it's here you
knowWhat he did the same as Mom.
I'm just going to let him know this is my
last trip soon as I go up thereAll right
doing this again.
Nope because the more that I think about it
the more just irritate me I'm going to go
see what people I can't really stand right
now I'm going up there to like
To hang out with him but it's like you dead
seriously told me that if you came out here
you were going to stay in the motel
When you just got mad at your sister for
telling you that she wouldn't come visit
your house
That's just that's what I'm that's what I'm
talking about like it's everybody posted
here but don't nobody care
Until Friday
No noPeople going to get enough for doing me
like this.
That's what I'm saying it's just getting to
the point where it be like I don't know if
you ever seen the movie I don't know what
movie I get it from but it's a movie where I
want to say it's Goofy and he be like when
the world turns their back on you you turn
your back on the world I'm going to turn
your back on the world
I think that's why I get up at times like
this
Buffalo directions
They could have just asked me for one
lifeCuz that's all right.
I'm going to be doing all day if you got
married
It's only 2 hours I don't really care about
that I'm so sorry and I know you yeah I got
to go early cuz somebody got to start
cooking
I don't got to be there that early I'm
showing up
I'm still going to be cookedIt's nice to be
cooked I mean she got to get there before me
cuz she got to cook I don't got to cook.
If I also have to cook I'm definitely not
going out there y'all can hang that up like
I've already I'm already well past my limits
And mind you that's crazy to think about my
family is only asking me to pull up and eatI
only want to do that.
I want to eatWith the cop supposed to sound
like me face a crazy wife.
I'm going up there going up there no more
That you need before me or that he was
supposed to wait on him since he got back
from the Army
That sound poetic
When she got four kids so I don't care don't
tell me you waited for me and you got four
kids
That's why I be feeling bad when I be
talking to baby mama like that too it's like
I hear her story and I feel for it and when
I can I help out like I said show me like
two or $300 right now
Oh I can't help her no more look at some
point you got toGet. Sugar daddy I don't
like you like that.
Because
Program leaving all that hair everywhere
leaving in a room
And they personally say they don't want it
in the room there's got to be free nah you
got them out here messing with me
Except to bring his chicken bones and shit
Cuz that's what he be knowing in the middle
of the night nobody see motherfucker be
digging in the trash and pulling stuff out
of them he did not prepare for me to pop out
when that chicken bone was supposed to fall
And I wonder how it's doing it cuz how did
it get the chicken bone from the bottom of
the bag to the top of the bag without
tearing the bag
On the outside of the bag so either somebody
didn't put that chicken wing all the way in
the bag
Which is very possibleYou know at least they
got it to the bag it's some people that
didn't even make it there.
Let's change keyNo I hate that plastic trash
can they bought broke.
Because nobody ever puts a bag in there and
people keep putting trash in there and
nobody wants to clean it
And then you see where I sleep
My head goes on either side like I literally
could go either way with it rightIf I go to
the kitchen side.
Them books they be flying around the trash
thoughThey look like dots but they be flying
I don't know how.
He does
Smack it
I need to start keeping track of how many
fouls get touched the bay
And generatesWith this.
I don't like driving a night I love you
though somebody just told me good night
Yeah I'm definitely not popping up before
the food I think this is going to be a
L trip too and that's the crazy thing I'm
going down there and knowing it might be a
hell trip
But like I'm saying oh yeah I just want some
stuff up
I know that
And I Know It Ain't Nothing turned off cuz I
didn't wanted to be hot going into the car
And maybe a little bit of Sam
That's the sound you hear that sounded the
same as I'm playing this video game
That loud at 1:30 a.m.
The rest of the pet is it bugging me and her
going to her room and ignoring the fact that
the cat is bugging me
And I'm a cat personI just don't want to be
bothered it doesn't.
It doesn't matter if they hitAnd told are
you that recently like I just don't want to
be back.
And we didn't get nothing done on code and
thatIt dipped out on cold and then. I'm
going to be mad at them too.